[Music]
circuit board of fairfax county is now
in session
all right good morning
all right do we have any preliminary
matters before we bring the jury out
okay good
oh thank you
okay that's fine which exhibit number is
it
1246 okay great all right perfect thank
you
all right you get the jury
46.
do
three
all right good morning ladies and
gentlemen
all right your next witness
uh good morning your honor ladies and
gentlemen mr depp calls terrence doherty
d-o-u-g-h-e-r-t-y
and for the first part of the deposition
it will be mr depp's counsel asking the
questions and then it will change and
we'll let you know thank you thank you
you
so
tell
dress
three six zero riverside drive
good morning mr doherty would you please
state your full name for the record
karen starti
what is your address
360 riverside drive
new york new york
10025
i went to oberlin college
i got a ba there
and with the majors in history and in
english and i studied theology gamba
performance at the oberlin conservatory
i then
spent uh took four years uh uh
four years after i graduated i went to
columbia law school
and what year did you receive your ba
from oberlin 1991
and what did you do in the four years
between your graduation from your
oberlin from oberlin and going to law
school i was a kindergarten teacher in
the south bronx at a homeless shelter
for a few years
and then i did freelance editing
work for a
an academic press named routledge and
simultaneously
was the writer research assistant to
feminist cultural critic bell hooks
and remind me sir where you went to law
school colombia
did you receive your jd from colombia i
did in what year was that
1998.
having received a jd from
colombia i take it you know what a
statute of limitations is is that
correct correct after receiving your jd
from columbia
what did you do in terms of your
professional life i worked at um freed
frank howard shriver and jacobson for
about four years
three and a half four years i was in
their tax department
um and after that i
went to
work at patterson belknap
and i was also in the tax department
there but worked on
um
primarily with their exempt organization
clients paterson has a large exempt
organization client practice
is it fair to say that you worked for mr
schwartz's firm patterson belknap from
about 2002 until about 2005. that's
that's exactly right
did there come a time you left paterson
belknap to work for the aclu foundation
correct
at the time you left was the aclu a
client of patterson belnap yes
and it continues to be
a client
until the present day correct correct
was there any time between 2005 and
today where patterson belnap ceased to
be a client of the aclu
no
you mean where the aclu seems to be kind
of person right yes thank you for that
correction yeah no we've uh we've been a
client the whole time not always with
active matters of course but a client
the whole time
in what capacity did you start at the
aclu foundation in 2005. i was the
aclu's first in-house lawyer
my title was senior corporate council
what were your responsibilities
generally when you began
as senior corporate counsel at the aclu
foundation
my role was to serve as the
organization's in-house lawyer and to
assess
what the needs were for an in-house
council
department or practice at the aclu
and i take it you have continued to work
as a lawyer at the aclu on an
uninterrupted basis from 2005 to the
current day correct my title changed
relatively soon after 2005.
um in either 2006 or early 2007 my title
was changed to general counsel
is that still your title today
it's part of my title i'm general
counsel and i'm also chief operating
officer
whom do you report
i report to anthony romero the um uh
executive director chief executive
officer
so that's a direct report there's no
intermediary between the two of you
correct direct report
sitting here today
do you know how much
money
ms heard has actually donated to the
aclu actually remitted to the aclu
yes i do how much is that
um so when you say remitted do you mean
direct
payments from her personally or do you
mean something payments on her behalf or
payments um you know from a
donor-advised fund that she might
have set up or
we can we can break it down let's let's
first from
how much
has
ms heard
paid directly to the aclu
i that would be
350 000 paid directly
how much
has been paid indirectly and credited
to ms hurd
um there was one hundred thousand
dollars um which was a check from johnny
depp
there was a five thousand five hundred
thousand dollar payment from
a donor advised fund at vanguard
and then there was a 350 000 payment
that appears to be from a donor-advised
fund at fidelity
making a total 1.2 million dollars
and when you speak
of
credit to credited toward amber heard to
what are you referring
um
so and i think i might have done the
math wrong let me just do the math in my
head is 700 800
plus the five i think 1.3 is the is the
amount um so um
we received the check from um
for the for the
the 100 000 payment we received a check
from
johnny depp's um
representatives and it was said to be
a payment in connection with um on
behalf of amber heard
um she confirmed that
the 500 000 payment um from vanguard
charitable um
she confirmed was a payment in connect
on her behalf
and the 350 000 payment um as well
when you say credited toward
uh
her what does that mean
well um she had um
when we initially um uh had contact with
amber heard in 2016
she indicated her desire to pay 3.5
million dollars to the aclu and
that was and and these were amounts that
were in relation to
that um
her having expressed that that's what
she wanted to pay to the aclu
so it's fair to say that she has not
donated 3.5 million dollars as of today
to the aclu true that's right when you
say that mr depp our client donated one
hundred thousand dollars to be credited
toward amber heard
did the aclu in fact credit that one
hundred thousand dollars toward the 3.5
million dollars miss heard promised to
donate to the aclu we do credit
did miss heard direct you to credit it
to the to her account as it were
we asked ms hurd if we should credit it
and she said that we should
with what person or entity
is vanguard charitable associated
so vanguard charitable is a
nonprofit that vanguard
the financial institution has set up
that allows
provides for a
a wide variety of
um donor advised funds for
um individuals to use for their
charitable giving
um so
there are many many there are thousands
of vanguard charitable donor advised
funds
um if you are asking specifically about
the one that we received the 500 000
contribution from
we believe that that is a
uh donor advised fund that was set up by
elon musk
who is elon musk
he's a
tech entrepreneur
and isn't he also a donor to the aclu
foundation in his own right
yes
but it's your testimony that as to the
500 000
dollars that came from vanguard
charitable
that that was associated with elon musk
correct
we don't we believe so but it is not
inconclusive
did the aclu have any communications
with elon musk about
the 500 000 contribution
yes
and please describe those communications
there is a document that we produced
that uh elon musk um
emails anthony romero um regarding the
five hundred thousand dollar
contribution
what did
miss heard tell mr romero or the aclu
about
her donation and how much she was going
to
contribute there were communications
back and forth between the aclu and miss
heard including a thank you
acknowledgement letter that mr
was sent under mr romero's name to
miss heard thanking her for the 350 000
contribution um noting that um that
it was part of her intention to make a
um 3.5 million dollar contribution to
the aclu and mr romero attached to that
communication a standard aclu pledge
form um that um
and so that was the communication
we were aware
very early on
that the
her intention to contribute the 3.5
million dollars to us was half of
her 7 million divorce proceedings um
i'm not i don't recall
which um specific communication with us
gave us that knowledge
what if any understanding
did
the aclu have
prior to the publication of the op-ed
about
ms heard's plans to dispose of the other
half of the seven million dollar
settlement or the other 3.5 million yes
we um
understood that the other 3.5 million
dollars the other half was going to
um
a children's hospital in los angeles
when did the first donation the three
hundred fifty thousand dollars from ms
heard actually
arrive at the aclu
it was very soon after
the communication between elon musk and
anthony and i believe that it was that
communication was in august of 2016 and
it was shortly thereafter
please describe your conversations with
ms white's
i asked ms white whether it was her
um
decision to
um
ask
ms heard to be an aclu ambassador
and she indicated that it was
um i asked
ms whites to
describe what are the criteria
for
sorry a calendar thing popped up um uh
what are the criteria
for
um
asking
for becoming an aclu ambassador
um
and i
yeah and what is and what were the
reasons why
um she thought that ms heard would be
an appropriate aclu ambassador
how did ms whites respond
she said that aclu ambassadors are
people who are
artists or influencers
that are aligned with one or two
aclu
policy issues
and the criteria
for
determining whether somebody can be an
ambassador
is that they have
prior expertise in that policy area
that they can speak in detail about the
area
that they are aligned with the aclu's
policy views of the area
and that they have
significant following so that
their
communications to the public that we
support
are reach
a wide variety of people
of those criteria
which did ms whites identify as the most
important if any
um
i don't think there's any that she did
not identify any as the most important
what if anything did miss whites tell
you about ms hurd's expertise in women's
rights
ms white said that she
had arranged a meeting between ms heard
and representatives of our women's
rights project and our reproductive
freedom project
and ms heard spoke with
such clarity and expertise on
issues of
gender-based violence
that she
decided that she would be an appropriate
person to ask to become an aclu
ambassador and she did so
what if anything did miss
whites tell you about ms hurd's
significant
following um
miss heard uh
ms white's said that she
um looked at um
ms heard social media
anything else
no
not that she said to me
all right let's look to topic six what
if anything did you do to prepare to
testify about your role
the aclu's role in the conception
preparation drafting or publication of
the op-ed
um i
reviewed the documents that we produced
i had three meetings with our lawyers i
spoke with
ms white and mr romero
please describe your
discussions with ms white
i asked
ms whites
whether
she
was um
involved
and what her involvement was with
respect to the
uh conception preparation drafting and
our publication of the op-ed and she
indicated that because of her role as
our director of artistic engagement
um she was involved in all aspects of
the
conception preparation drafting and
publication
and that um
the
other
members of the
communications department
who worked on this um even though they
didn't necessarily report to her in
terms of our hierarchy
they reported to her in terms of this
specific task she was the person who was
um who was the director of this project
did ms white tell you that she
participated in the drafting of the
op-ed
she was in
she she yes yes
yes other than miss white's
were there any other lawyers at the aclu
involved in the drafting of the op-ed
ms white's is not a lawyer
so were there
were there
lawyers involved in the um
in the drafting of the op-ed i believe
it was the drafting of the op-ed that
was all done within the communications
department
what is ms white's uh academic
background
um i don't know her academic background
was any aclu lawyer and i mean in-house
lawyer involved in the drafting of the
op-ed
i believe the answer is yes i believe
that there are documents that support
back and forth between
support for the op-ed but but i'm but i
don't recall i don't recall sitting here
today do you know how many aclu lawyers
were involved in the drafting of the
op-ed no i don't
were there any aclu lawyers involved in
the
reviewing of the op-ed before it was
submitted to the washington post yes
there were
how many
um
i think there were four
were you one of the four
no i was not one of the four and and to
be clear when you were when when what i
was referring to were people in our
legal department who are experts on um
women's rights issues um i was there was
nobody from
neither i nor anybody on in-house
council team was involved in the um in
the drafting of the op-ed or the review
of the op-ed
oh why not we were not brought we were
not involved we were not brought into
the loop i don't know why
is it fair to say that the aclu didn't
think there was any
there were any potential legal
implications
to the aclu
involved in the publication of the op-ed
i have not spoken with any of the
lawyers in the legal department about
whether they um thought it would be
you know would be necessary to um
uh to involve any member of my in-house
counsel team on the uh in the review of
the op-ed
who were the four
attorneys in-house
at the aclu who were involved in
reviewing the op-ed before it was
submitted to the washington post okay so
i was referring to people in the legal
department not the in-house counsel's
office on the legal department who do
our work
our civil liberties uh litigation and
advising on legal issues relating to
civil liberties and i believe that the
um op-ed the four was reviewed by
lenora lapidus
um
david cole
i believe louise melling was involved
um
and there may have also been a fellow
that was involved in reviewing it um
these are all um
there are
a number of back and forth emails that
we produced that
will
uh indicate specifically who those
people were okay let's move to exhibit
two please
yesterday alive
mr doherty have you ever seen this
document before yes what is it
these are conversations within the aclu
communications department about um
uh ms heard
donations to the aclu
and um
um and
the
possible
engagement
of
that issue as a communications matter
for the aclu
mr daugherty if we could start in the
email in the uh middle of the first page
of exhibit two the middle of the first
page okay
yes who is stacy sullivan stacy sullivan
was a
a senior person in our communications
department
is she still at the aclu no
when did she leave
um
i don't recall the date
who is steven smith
stephen smith um
at the time
was our associate director for strategic
communications now he is the
deputy communications director
and i believe you testified uh
earlier that
mr romero came first came to learn about
this through elon musk is that right
correct tell us exactly
who aclu media is you said it's
it's an email account that is monitored
by members of the communication staff so
that when media inquiries come in
rather than them going to a specific
individual in the communications
department who could be working on
something else or on leave it goes to a
central
email account that is then monitored and
uh
direct and emails within it are directed
to
the appropriate people
who's sandra
i
assume that is sandra park who is a
a lawyer in our women's rights project
was she uh was miss park involved in the
op-ed in any way either reviewing or
approving
i believe she was
that coverage
is good for the aclu correct
yes
and the press coverage among other
things enabled the aclu to promote its
work helping victims of prevention
domestic violence correct
correct
specifically how does the aclu record
donations
we record donations in our
donor database
it's referred in the trade
um as a
crm a constituent record management
system
and at this time
we
um
our
crm was
um
was a company called pidi
at this point our crm is is with
salesforce
is there anyone at the aclu who
interacts or who interacted with
pidi
there are many members of our
development department
that
interact with
interacted with pidi with respect to the
functioning support of that system
and the vendor relationship
and then and i'm not sure if you're
asking this but then there are a number
of people in the development department
who can input donor information into
this database i don't see them as having
interaction with pidi but it's with our
database
what type of information is
um it's very broad
the names address contact information
donations
hit prior history with
donations um
issues that they are particularly
interested in
it it's it's also
differs depending on the nature of the
donor if somebody gives a
50 annual donation
that is recorded if somebody is a
3 million a year donor to the aclu a
different level of information is is um
is is reported and this is recorded in
the system if someone makes a donation
on behalf of a mobile person or to be
credited to another person how is that
reported by the aclu
um
it is reported um as
it is reported as such as um as
uh relating to but there's many
different ways that that could um
somebody could
give on behalf of somebody else people
can make a gift in honor of somebody
else people can make a gift in order to
fulfill someone else's pledge people can
make a gift um you know
a donor may help
bring another donor to the aclu all of
that information is is recorded in our
systems
can a donor earmark
his or her donation
for a particular purpose absolutely
after miss heard announced her
donation for the aclu
what specifically did the aclu do to
document that donation
um
well we
sent out
a note to amber thanking her for the
donation
um that is likely the contribution
acknowledgement letter that mimi is
referring to
um and that information was kept in our
files and the
information regarding ms heard
was
recorded in our
sales force or at the time pidi database
at the time the aclu said misheard the
acknowledgement letter
was it the aclu's expectation that the
3.5 million dollars would be played by
ms heard
in uh all at once in a lump sum
no i do not believe it was i believe
that
that we believe that it would
based on the based on the elon musk
email we thought that it might be
that it was intended to be over a
10-year period um although
[Music]
that was never um specifically confirmed
uh well that's
interesting um
what email are you referring to
i believe that the first email from elon
musk to anthony romero or said that it
was over a 10-year period
anything else
to make the aclu believe that ms heard
was not paying the money right away out
of her divorce settlement with mr deb
anthony in his communications with ms
heard referred to the amount as a pledge
and a pledge is generally
what a pledge means is that the amount
is not necessarily paid all at once it's
pledged to the organization rather than
just sending a check there's a
some kind of
varying levels of commitment made
to
give amounts over a period of time which
is
excuse me um
uh
useful for the
for the charity to know so that it can
um make
future projections as to income mr
dougherty who if anyone at the aclu
was assigned
to
handle or track
ms heard's donation
um that would have been two different um
people depending on what you mean by
track
there is a person in our leadership
gifts department which is the department
that deals with
high-level donors his name is john
maresco and his role is to in addition
to um facilitating maintaining the
relationship with those donors is to um
uh
to
oversee the um back and forth with those
donors for annual giving
so in this case that would include
ms heard's gifts to the aclu and then
there's a second
group within the development department
that is the team that maintains the
overall donor database the then pidi now
salesforce database
exhibit
was exhibit nine uh prepared in the
ordinary course of the aclu's business
um it's not back up on the screen yet
okay here it is
yes it was
is it maintained in the ordinary course
of the aclu's business
yes
were these emails
to your knowledge prepared
contemporaneously with people having
knowledge of contents
correct
okay if we could please move ahead to
exhibit 11.
insert standby
okay i see it
daugherty you've ever seen this document
before i have was this one of the
documents that you reviewed in
preparation for your deposition today
yes is this was this prepared in the
ordinary course of the aclu's business
yes was it maintained in the ordinary
course of the aclu's business
yes
was it prepared
by mr romero
contemporaneously
uh
on or about september 19th 2016.
it was prepared by someone in our
development department who i believe to
be mimi clara but yes to the rest of you
most romero have knowledge of the
contents of this letter that he signed
yes
so he states uh to ms heard
thank you for your wonderful gift of 350
000 to the aclu
the first installment of your very
generous pledge of 3.5 million
uh you see that
yes so as of uh october 9th 2016
ms hurd had our had actually donated
only 350 000 correct
correct
uh now if you would please turn to the
next page i believe you referred to this
before but if you could just clear it up
for the record
um have you ever seen this page before
and it's called pledge form
page number aclu 3033
yes i have
what is it
this is a document that is used
well
in the generic document is one that is
used regularly by the development
department this one in particular is
branded in connection with our 100th
year anniversary but that's just a
branding thing um what the form is is a
form for people who are making pledges
to the aclu to
document that um
that promise in the in in a form like
this and when a form like this is filled
out um we
see that as a um as
that that documents the the the
full amount that they intend to
contribute and the time period over
which those gifts are going to be made
and is it your understanding sir that um
this these
this pledge form
and the two documents after an aclu 3034
and 3035
were in fact attached to the letter mr
romero sent miss hurd on september 9
2016. yes
and who prepared
this uh aclu 3033 that pledged for
i believe that
well it was somebody in our development
department um i don't know whether it
was mimi clara or john maresco or
someone else but it was somebody who was
preparing it in connection with the
preparation of the tax acknowledgement
letter
there's a reference um
on top of the pledge form amber heard
carol pierce o'donnell
greenberg wesker and then there's some
other names do you know what
the firm greenberg klusker had to do
with amber heard
no
and you have no idea why
it was said to misheard
care of mr o'donnell at greenberg lesker
the i expect that um
it is the case that
well many of our significant donors have
representatives that we
work directly with
on uh
technical things such as a pledge form
okay and directing uh your attention to
the next uh page that was attached to
mr romero's letter it also says pledge
form but it has
some
columns yes
is it fair to say that this is a
proposed schedule
for payment of the remaining 3.5 million
dollar donation
that is what it is
and do you know that who
came up with this proposed schedule
i um
don't know who
[Music]
prepared this form
and don't know
who told the person
who prepared this form
to do the gift payment schedule in this
way
did
you see at the bottom of that page aclu
3034
part of exhibit 11
that there is a
signature line
correct yes i do
did miss heard ever sign
this pledge schedule
no
did anyone
at greenberg gloucester or anyone else
on behalf of miss heard ever sign this
form
no
why not
i don't know the answer
did miss heard ever agree to any
schedule for the payment
of her 3.5 million dollar donation
there are documents that we produced
that
point to miss heard being aware of this
as a multi-year commitment including the
elon musk emailed to anthony
and back and forth between anthony and
amber
on an annual basis about her
about this gift
my question was actually a simple one
did miss heard ever agree to any
schedule
for the payment of the remainder
of the 3.5 million dollar donation i
don't recall her having um seeing
anything where she agreed to
a 10-year schedule like this
let's go uh now please back to exhibit
10.
so standby
okay um
mr daugherty have you ever seen this
exhibit exhibit 10 before
i have
what is it
this is
an email
exchange
that includes
anthony romero
our director of development mark weir
the executive director of our southern
california affiliate which encompasses
la
and me
regarding
the
check that we received
from
johnny depp's representatives in the
amount of a hundred thousand dollars
was it
prepared in the ordinary course of the
aclu's business
yes was it maintained by the aclu in the
ordinary course of its business
yes with these emails prepared uh
contemporaneously by people having
knowledge of the content
yes
okay let's move please to um
the second page of the exhibit
the email
from
hector villagra
to
anthony romero
dated august 25 2016 at 12 44 p.m did
have you do you see that
um
[Music]
12
you know at the bottom of this page at
the bottom of this page okay sorry yep
12 44 yes
is anthony anthony romero yes
and who is hector villagra
hector
is the executive director of the aclu of
southern california
and
you see where he informs mr romero the
actual check is for mr deb
care of his cpa and handwritten on the
check it says donation
being made in the name of amber
bird so i think you've testified that
the aclu in fact received a hundred
thousand dollar check from johnny depp
correct correct
and do you know why mr depp asked that
it be uh credited
uh to the name of amber heard no i don't
mr villagra tells mr romero that
he has been
designated or that he has been the point
person what does that mean
um hold on let me just find that
it's at the very end of the exhibit on
the next page oh okay
my staff let me know that you have been
the point person yes um hector is saying
that anthony was the main
person with the relationship with amber
as a donor
and why was mr romero the point person
mr romero is um
our
uh one of our most significant
fundraisers at the organization and he
has a specific portfolio of um donors
that he and his
team
such as john maresco
support
and do you see going back to the second
page of the exhibit
mr romero's response to mr villagra a
copy to mark weir
that same day
or strike that on august 25th you see
that
i do
now let's let's move back to the first
page
and and do you see the email from mark
weiler to hector villagra copy to mimi
clara
honor about august 25th at 11 12 a.m
so he says just spoke with anthony who
got off
strike that just spoke with anthony who
just got off the phone
with elon musk
and anthony uh refers to anthony romero
correct correct
why was mr romero discussing the herd
donation with elon musk my understanding
is that anthony reached out to elon musk
because he had a prior relationship with
elon musk and elon musk was the person
who first contacted anthony about the
donation
about a donation from amber and wasn't
mr romero specifically asking him
about
mr depp's donation of a hundred thousand
dollars
that's how i read this email yes
and if and if you look down
just below that um
the email from mr villagra to mark weir
and he says got it we will hold the
check that's a reference to the aclu's
holding the check from johnny depp
correct that's how i read this
okay so now moving back up to that email
from mr weiler to mr villagra copy to
mimi clara
he says we're going to draft an email
from anthony to amber explaining the
situation and asking for her advice what
is what does he mean there i take that
to mean that we wanted to hear from
amber regarding whether this gift was um
attributable to the amounts that she
wanted to contribute to the aclu
did the aclu in fact reach out to ms
hurd about mr depp's 100 000 donation
yes there are documents that we produced
that um show a back and forth on that
point
between anthony and miss hurd and mr
weiler
or mr weir writes
i'll keep you in the loop but definitely
hold the check until we get clearance
from amber
why would the aclu
need clearance from amber heard before
it accepted a hundred thousand dollar
donation from johnny depp
my understanding of this is that we
would have that we wanted to know
whether this before we cached this check
whether it was in relation to the amber
herd
desire to contribute to the aclu as
opposed to a separate um desire by
johnny depp to contribute to us
individually and in fact the
communication from johnny depp's
representatives said that it was in
connection with amber heard so we wanted
to clarify what was going on
so moving to the email directly above
that from victor villagra hector
villagra to mark weir
he says
we have more folks than i knew who
followed tmg here's their latest report
amber heard calls bs on johnny's charity
donation
now you owe double
uh what's that a reference to i don't
really know specifically other than to
say that this is
more indication that we were unclear of
whether
this the johnny depp gift would count
toward the amounts that amber said she
wanted to contribute to the aclu
and then uh directing your attention to
the top email on exhibit 10
mr weir responds she's calling johnny
out on the 14 million dollars in the
press what does that refer to
i don't know i don't know i'm not aware
of
how 14 million
plays into any of this
okay let's move ahead um
to exhibit 12 please
mr daugherty have you ever seen this
document before
um just making it larger yes i have
and what is it
um this is
amber confirming
that
we
can that we we can cash mr depp's check
and did ms heard in fact send this to mr
romero on or about
october 17
2016. yes
and is this a document that
was created in the ordin was maintained
in the ordinary course of the aclu's
business
yes
and it's true that the aclu ultimately
deposited mr depp's check for uh for a
hundred thousand dollars correct
correct
did
the aclu
credit
the one hundred thousand dollars paid by
mr depp
toward
ms hurd's 3.5 million dollar pledge or
donation
we do credit that 100 000 amount toward
the
um
uh toward amber herds um
[Music]
charitable giving to the aclu where if
at all is that credit reflected in the
aclu's records
um there are documents that we produced
that show
the
fact
that
this was
considered part of
amber heard's charitable giving to the
aclu
after at the aclu received ms herd's
initial 350 000 payment it received
press inquiries about the herd donation
correct correct
how many
oh i don't know the specific number
sorry
was this document exhibit 20 uh
maintained in the ordinary coerce of the
acls used business yes was it prepared
in the ordinary course of the aclu's
business contemporaneously by people
having knowledge of the contents
yes
on what date was miss heard appointed an
aclu ambassador
it was in october of 2018. okay let's
move ahead please to exhibit 22. the
aclu ever issue a press release
regarding
the vanguard 500 000 contribution
i don't believe we ever um issued a
press release in 2017 regarding amber
heard's donations to the ac
why not
um
they're we received an email from
amber that is in the documents that says
um that we do
that
says that we that we don't need to do
this we shouldn't do this on that this
uh press release let's go to 24 please
standby
mr daugherty have you ever seen this
document exhibit 24 before yes
what is it
um this is uh anthony in his email to
the one we just saw said that his comms
people were going to be reaching out to
um amber's people
and um so steve then starts that process
and amber then he sees see then amber
responds and says that she's no longer
working with pierce
and introduces steve to her new lawyer
eric george
and um
she indicates um
that she
has a concern about um about
issuing a press statement is this
document maintained in the ordinary
course of the aclu's business
yes was it prepared in the ordinary
course of the aclu's business
yes
and was it prepared uh contemporaneously
by people having knowledge of its
contents
yes
i'd like to direct your attention uh to
the
email at the top of
the page
um
you see the email at the top of the page
from miss heard
to jody gottlieb and others dated
july 6 2017
i do
have you ever seen this document before
yes
what is it
this is
amber
letting steve know that she's no longer
working with pierce but instead working
with a new lawyer
and indicating to steve that she is
going to be talking with her pr team
about whether
uh about
issuing a press statement about her 2017
issuing a press statement about her 2017
gift
and directing your attention uh she
writes
their concern is that the press could
potentially spin the fact
that this
is an installment
and not the entire lump sum
as you well know isn't possible due to
the structure of the settlement
agreement
um
the settlement
agreement is a reference to the
settlement agreement
between johnny depp and amber heard of
their divorce correct i
read that to um reference to the
settlement agreement to
be the settlement agreement between herd
and death but i don't have any
independent knowledge of that
what was the basis of your belief that
she was going to pay you every year
the original communications
and her response to us when we reached
out to her and she
indicated you know uh on a
a number of occasions that this was
something that she was going to be
taking she was going to be looking into
but she didn't do it did she what we did
receive was a the 500 000 vanguard
charitable contribution
um the and then the next year the 350
000 contribution she didn't pay you on
an annual basis did she
yes we didn't receive any amounts in
2019 and on let's move up to the middle
email on the page
uh mr weir to steve smith
thanks steve her gift is technically
unrestricted but it is weighted towards
women's rights issues what does that
mean what that means is that there's a
particular um
type of
um
gift that is
legally restricted for a specific
purpose and um that could be that the
the restriction could be um done in a
number of ways
that was not done in this situation
but nonetheless um the the
intention in making gifts to the aclu
was to support that work
um so there's that subtle distinction
and and this is not an uncommon one at
the aclu
after the vanguard payment of 500 000 in
july 2017
what if any
payments did miss heard make
to the aclu
there was one more payment um
of 350 000 that came from um fidelity
charitable so it looked to be from a
donor-advised fund fidelity
and when was that donor advised
fidelity payment made in 2018
so
oh we have a document that we produced
that um shows
the um contributions that we've received
from fidelity charitable and um and the
timing for each of those one of which
includes um
is includes the amber herd
350. okay if we could please move to
exhibit 39
i'm showing you what's been marked as
exhibit 39 have you ever seen this
document before hold on can we get the
bait stamp number please it is
3037
aclu
thank you
uh you're welcome
i'm directing your attention
to the penultimate
entry on
that page
yes there appears to be a reference well
first of all have you ever seen this
document before i have and what is it
this is a document that we created that
um
lists the contributions made to the
aaclu
um on a specific date
december 11 2018
that came from the online at fidelity
charitable account
and is this document
maintained in the ordinary course of the
aclu's business
the information in this is maintained in
the ordinary course of this business we
created this document um in um
uh in response to the discovery requests
and
does it truthfully and accurately
reflect
the donations made
to the aclu online
on or about december 11 2018. i believe
that it does it is a document that i
believe our development department
pulled information from salesforce our
current crm into an excel and that's
what this is
so directing your attention to the
penultimate
[Music]
entry on this page
said
350 000 designation
colon don't uh donation from amber heard
what does that refer to
um what that refers to is that since um
the
giving account are the names of the
fidelity charitable donor advised funds
which is the column and the right
this one is designated as anonymous
meaning that the
person who set up the donor advice fund
in this case i believe amber
wanted it to be an anonymous daughter
anonymous donor advice fund so that
would be within her discretion to decide
which gifts were were that she
recommended um were her recommendations
are not and so we put into this special
purpose category um the we marked that
this was a donation from amber heard
meaning a recommendation from her to
make a contribution from her governor
advised fund
so this is a
an anonymous donation for someone in
amber heard's name correct it is
anonymous to the
this is
when when this donor advice was fun was
set up it was determined that it would
be that the gifts would presumptively be
anonymous unless um she were to
recommend just state otherwise
and did she ever state otherwise
um we um
were we we believed that this was um
that she that she indicated that this
was her 350 000 gift and that's why we
put into the sp the column that this was
a donation um recommended by her from
her donor advice fund
the money did not come from her correct
the money
went from her to her donor advised fund
and then she recommended that
the funds be paid from fidelity to us so
the amount that 350 we received did not
come from her directly it came from what
we believe to be her donor advice funded
fidelity that she said
what
basis other than miss herds telling you
does the aclu have
for the proposition
that ms heard
paid the money to fidelity
before it came and was given to the aclu
the
what we have is what she told us which
is how this how donor advised funds that
are anonymous work
the only amount that the only thing that
we legally needed to know was that this
came from the fidelity charitable and
that's the kind of reporting that we
would do on this for example if we were
reporting on this gift in our tax
filings or anything like that we then
are our donors who have donor advised
funds they then let us know that they
made that recommendation and we then
credited to them as being associated
with their giving to us in our um uh crm
well mr d dougherty i didn't ask you
what the aclu was legally
required to do i asked you
what if anything the aclu did
to investigate whether in fact ms hurt
provided
the funds to fidelity and your answer is
nothing right
i don't
know i don't believe there was anything
else i don't know what else we would
have gotten
so just so the record is clear
the aclu relied only on ms heard
that she was the ultimate source of the
fidelity funds correct yes
because you've already testified that ms
heard was not the original source of the
funds
for the 500 000 vanguard contribution
correct
we received that 500 000 from vanguard
their 501c3 not from any other
person
right but vanguard was associated with
mr musk true we believe that to be the
case yes
so after
this december 2018
donation
has miss heard made any
donations directly or indirectly to the
aclu
no though those are the four
contributions the one that we've just
before that we've discussed
well we're almost um
three years since her last contribution
what if any
efforts has the aclu
made
to get amber heard to pay
um we reached out to
her
we um
reached out to ms hurd starting in 2019
for the next um installment of her
giving
and um
we learned that she was having financial
difficulties
well let's let's uh unpack that so
uh when in 2019 did the aclu reach out
to ms hurd about making uh her promised
contributions
i don't recall the date but there is a
document that we produced that was an
email from um anthony to
uh amber about this in 2019
okay let's move ahead to um
exhibit uh 67 please
have you seen these documents these
attachments before
yes i've seen these okay and we'll just
go through them one by one if you don't
mind sure if you look at bates number
4673
[Music]
um it refers it it says 350 000
december 11 2018
uh what is that
um
i believe this is um this tracks with
the excel spreadsheet that we looked at
just a few moments ago that talks about
online giving to the fidelity charitable
fund and
the whereas the prior one listed all of
the december 11 2018 gifts this one
lists the 350 000 gift from uh that
from the amber's
donor advice fund
um and moving to the next page it says
designation
donor from amber heard do you see that
yes
what does designation mean
um so this was the um column in um
salesforce that allows us to include
additional information about gifts in
particular whether they are restricted
in a certain way and um so so that's why
the term designation is used and here i
think we filled into that designation
field the information that we knew to be
the case which was that this was a
recommendation from donor from amber
heard stoner advice fund
okay now if you move to the next page
4675
there's just one word on that and it's
anonymous do you know what that means
this corresponds to the column of that
same spreadsheet that listed the names
of the donor advised funds that
individuals set up at um at fidelity and
and that the name of the amber one was
anonymous
now when ms heard made her
direct payment
her first contribution
of 350 000
that was not designated as anonymous
wasn't it was it that was not a gift
from a donor-advised fund so there
weren't those columns for us to fill out
um it was it was just a
gift to the aclu and i do believe that
in anthony's um acknowledgement letter
to that that included the pledge form
that wasn't signed um
he
included a question about anonymity and
whether we could list her as a donor in
our annual report so that was our first
connection with her so um you know we
weren't sure whether her giving would be
anonymous or not
well the first donation wasn't anonymous
correct
um
no because we no it was not anonymous
but but what i'm saying here is that
this is this is the name i believe this
is the name of her donor advised funded
fidelity and the first time she gave us
a gift i think it came right out of her
own um you know her own uh banking
accounts right and between the time ms
heard made her
first donation of 350 000 directly which
is attributed directly to her
and the time this anonymous
donation comes in
did anybody at the aclu have any
discussion with miss hurt as to whether
she wanted uh anonymity
i don't believe she
did i don't believe she did okay if you
could move ahead please to um
page number
four six
seven eight
yes
have you ever seen this document before
yes
what is it
this is the um document that vanguard
charitable so vanguard's 501c3 nonprofit
uses when someone makes a recommendation
from a vanguard charitable donor advised
fund to give an amount to a charity
and they then send this letter
saying that they vanguard
are giving this amount to the charity
and it describes
whether this is the document that would
describe whether or not the
donor wants to be anonymous or even
wants to indicate to us
who they are
and this is the vanguard contribution
about which you testified earlier
correct correct
let's move ahead please to
466
which is the next page yes
and have you ever seen this document
before i have and is this one of the
documents that you reviewed in the
context of preparing for this deposition
yes
and directing your attention to uh the
middle of the page it says remark
from amber heard
what does that
signify
this
i'm sorry i'm counting the three seconds
um this is um
uh a
record of a wire into our accounts at jp
morgan chase
in the amount of three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
from amber heard's account
and city national bank and this was her
first
contribution correct
yes this is the 2016
august contribution
okay and if you could move ahead please
uh to the next page
aclu4680 have you ever seen this
document before
i have
what is it
this is um
the original
email from elon
to amber and anthony
um describing her plan to donate to the
aclu over the next 10 years
and her support for our work
and um
and that she wasn't restricting the gift
she just had a preference
about the use of the funds
and
that
anthony would forward her the wiring
instructions and then he did so and then
the
350 000 was wired as we saw in that last
jpmorgan chase aclu bank account wire
record and so anthony let amber know
that we received it
okay so let's unpack that a little bit
so
the email in the
middle of the page
was an email sent to mr romero
from elon musk on or about august 18
2016 at 1 14 p.m correct
correct and he says amber i described
your plan to donate 3.5 million to the
aclu over the next 10 years
as you very much believe
in what they are doing
you see that yes
why
was
ms heard
or strike that why was mr musk
representing this on behalf of miss
heard
i don't know the answer to that question
but assume it's because of elon's prior
relationship with anthony
and that he indicated i will make that
introduction for you he is representing
that miss herd's plan was to donate 3.5
million dollars over the next 10 years
is that correct correct that that was
her plan
did ms heard ever say in words or
substance that mr musk was
not correct and that wasn't her plan i
do not believe she ever said that
so she never refuted mr musk's
representation that she was going to
apply pay the full 3.5 million dollars
correct
it isn't the case that she
didn't object to that she was going to
pay the 3.5 it's just that she didn't
object that that was her plan as of
august 18th 2016.
thank you mr dougherty let's move to the
next page
which is 4681
yes
and you see
at the top it says
salesforce screenshot would you remind
us please what salesforce is
it's our current crm our constituent
record management system which is where
we store
all the information we have about our
donors we call it our donor database
and and i believe that
we've seen a version of this in an email
from mr
mourinho or maresco correct
i do recall that this um document this
is part of documents that we produced
okay well let's let's start um
from the bottom uh sure um
if you look at the
bottom entry in the column
it it
has the entry that has a closed date 8
19 2016
completed 350 000
uh what does that mean
um that's a record of her 350 000
contribution to us
and you see the um
designation
the giving name pledge payment
i do
what does that refer to that this was in
connection with her overall plan to make
a contribution to us of 3.5 million
dollars
okay now let's move up to um
the entry in the middle of the chart
it says miss amber heard soft credit
2017
[Music]
close date
june 12 2017
completed 500 000 what does that mean
that's the
record of the vanguard charitable
contribution in 2017
why does it say soft credit instead of
pledge payments
because it didn't come directly from
amber it came from the vanguard
charitable trust uh travel fund
and we wanted to continue to associate
it though with amber in our
uh
our
donor database
is it customary for the aclu to make
distinctions between hard donations that
is coming directly from the donor
and
donations uh made by others in the
donor's name
it's extremely important for us to
understand
who whether funds came
directly to us
from a donor from a donor's donor
advised fund or from another donor
altogether that's all very helpful
information to us as we um think through
our
fundraising program
but my question was is it is it common
practice and it sounds like it is common
practice because you say it's important
correct i believe it's a common practice
i believe it's a common practice
okay and then let's look at the top
entry in the chart
yes this is for the december 2018
payment and i believe you testified this
is the last payment ms heard has made
correct
correct and it says ms amberheard
donation
2018 payment
um
what does this signify
this signifies the this relates to the
2018 350 000
um gift that we got which i believe came
from amber's
donor vice funded fidelity
okay and let's
close this out by looking at
4682
reports to be an email from liz
fitzgerald to jonathan maresco who is
liz fitzgerald
liz fitzgerald's
then title was director of special gifts
but her current title is the director of
development she's the number two
in our development department she
reports directly to mark weir
and even then as director of special
gifts she reported directly to mark weir
okay
all right and with respect to exhibit 67
um
the attachments that we've described
were they created in the ordinary course
of the aclu's business
the only one
that i would not say was
in our ordinary course of business is
number
um
4681
in that this was created
in connection with um
a
discussion with um
uh with amber heard attorneys about um
amber's donations to the aclu but all of
the other documents in this exhibit were
created in the ordinary course of the
seo youth business correct correct and
even this one came from our donor
database which is something that we keep
in the ordinary course of our business
and it's your testimony sitting here
today that acl the information depicted
on aclu
4681
is accurate and reflects
the accounting records kept in the
aclu's ordinary course of business
correct it is correct that we received
the 350 the 500 and the 350 and that we
associated them all in some way with
amber it does not list the 100 000
johnny depp payment and um
and yeah and and there's differing
there's differing terms that are used in
in that i'm not sure we would use the
term soft credit we might refer to
another way now um after
that 2017 gift um that's when we
launched the new database system the
salesforce system and prior it had been
the pidi system so we had been doing
some changes to definitions about how we
record gifts but the basic which is that
these are all associated with amber
heard these three gifts that is
absolutely accurate
well you raised a good point why isn't
the 100 000
donated by johnny depp credited uh to
amber heard
i think it should have been recorded in
our database because it's information
that we would want to have in that
database about gifts relating to
our relationship with amber heard
and we now do consider
that gift as part of the
constellation of gifts that are
attributed to our relationship with
amber heard
so that's how you would get from the 1.2
million to the 1.3 million right
yes 700 plus 8 plus 1 is hundred plus
five hundred is one point three correct
so the aclu sitting here today
attributes 1.3 million dollars
toward
ms heard's 3.5 million dollar pledge
correct
correct and of that 1.3 million dollars
100 000 was paid by johnny depp true
correct
so putting this side 4681
all of the emails uh
prepared
by
aclu employees in the course of their
ordinary business
yeah i'm just reminding myself um
well it i believe that that 46
79 was also
um
print created downloaded from our
records in relation to this litigation
matter
i don't believe that we created this
document and had it in a paper file
somewhere um but i think we we you know
pulled this information this wiring
information
um
it may be the same wiring information
that was looked at at the time that the
donation was made
so exhibit 67 it's fair to say is
comprised of aclu
business records kept and maintained in
the ordinary course correct
correct
okay
excuse me your honor we're we're going
to uh change topics with mr daugherty
morning break thank your honor all right
uh let's go ahead and take our 15 minute
recess do not discuss the case with
anybody don't do the outside research
and we'll see you then okay
all right let's go ahead and come back
and take a break until 11 45 okay all
right thanks
all right are you ready for the jury
okay
okay
you
all right if you want to continue
have you ever seen this document before
yes
what is it
this is
a
a series of communications among people
in our
communications department
around
engaging
amber
on our programmatic work specifically
relating to her
being an aclu ambassador
let's now turn back to the email
starting on aclu 47.
bottom of the page from
gary johnson to jody gottlieb and others
yeah
um
reportedly dated november 6 2018 who's
jerry johnson
jerry johnson was a more junior person
in our um uh communications department
his title was communications department
strategist and strategists are often
communications department associates
that have um
expertise in and do work in
a select number of our issue areas okay
he writes um
i'd like your and amber's thoughts on
doing an op-ed in which she discusses
the ways in which survivors of
gender-based violence
have been made
less safe under the trump administration
and how people can take action
why
was the aclu recommending that amber
write on that subject
um
with amber
um
agreeing to be an ambassador and to work
on women's rights issues and in
particular issues of gender-based
violence
um jerry
um was coming up with specific things
that were things that were of
significant policy importance to the
aclu that could be the subject matter of
an op-ed written by amber
directing your attention
a few lines down
he uses the acronym gbv what does that
mean
gender-based violence
then further down he says if she feels
comfortable
she can interweave her personal story
saying how painful it is as a gbv
survivor to witness these setbacks
what is
the aclu referring to when it talks
about her personal story
um
there were a number of things that amber
had expressed
from her personal story about her um
having been
a
survivor of gender-based violence
and so
one of the things that we do with
ambassadors is
we
uh want them to tell authentic stories
about our issues in the public and to
the extent that they have any personal
um direct experiences
for that to be part of their um story
for the public
the aclu was not forcing her to relate
her own experience with gbv it was
leaving it up to ms hurd's discretion
correct correct
an exhibit 31
was prepared in the ordinary course of
the aclu's business correct
correct and it was
maintained in the ordinary course of the
aclu's business correct
correct let's move to exhibit 33 please
mr daugherty asking you to please look
at exhibit 33 and ask whether you've
ever seen this before
i have
you the email from robin shulman to
jessica white's uh dated
november 14th at 10 58 a.m
yes
who is jessica shulman
uh robin shulman is a person in the
communications department
um who is no longer with us but who had
expertise in issues involving
gender issues well you anticipated my
next question is um
robin shulman
still at the aclu
no
and is she an attorney
i don't know whether she's an attorney a
number of our communications department
staff members are but i don't know she
wasn't working as an attorney miss
shulman is asking miss white what is
this what's the status of this situation
what situation was she referring to the
situation is whether we are going to be
doing an op-ed with amber
okay and
moving up on the page
there's an email from jerry johnson
who says quote
jeff had drinks with amber last night
and it sounds like she was able to
confirm with her that we'll be doing the
first draft
what does that mean
um it is
often a decision has to be made when
we're working with ambassadors or with
other um people who are speaking to the
public who does the first draft of the
um document so
it sounds here that um jerry is saying
that we are
that from jess's conversation with amber
we are moving forward with some kind of
an op-ed and that aclu um
communications department staff members
would be writing the first draft of it
and jess refers to jessica white's
yes
okay let's please turn to exhibit 35
please
uh have you ever seen this document
before mr dougherty
and yes i have seen this document thanks
michael i have been i didn't say what is
it
this is um
a
series of communications about
the um
it's the result of a series of
communications about the
op-ed that amber
under amber's name to place um with the
media outlet and so um this is jessica
white's
sending a draft of that
to
um
to
amber
great and let's go to the first email
first um
the email that starts
in the second half of aclu 185
um
it purports to be from robin shulman to
jessica white's on november 29 do you
see that i do
and
is she attaching the first draft of the
op-ed
to that email
um
so i assumed that it was not an
attachment but it was a it was just
pasted into an email but i can't tell
from this
um
does i don't think see anybody saying
attached so it could be either
but what i see this as is robin
sending a note to jess weiss for jess
whites to then forward to amber
understood um
robin says
i tried to gather your fire and rage and
really interesting analysis and shape
that into an op-ed form
what does that refer to
that refers to the effort for
our aclu ambassadors to speak publicly
in a way that is
impactful
that is um shows um
the importance of the issues and how
important they are personally to
individuals
um
and in this case therefore
um amber's passion for
working on gender based violence issues
and speaking about it
and um that she has an analysis that is
one that robin finds interesting
and so when she's referring to fire and
rage that's miss herd's firing raids
correct yeah that's my read of this even
though i recognize that it is confusing
because it's an email from robin to jess
and the rage would be directed against
johnny depp
who purportedly abused her correct
i didn't take it to mean that i took it
to mean fire and rage about gender-based
violence issues
was it your understanding that it was
robin schulman who drafted
who prepared the first draft of the
op-ed
yes
okay
and robin says to jessica your lawyers
should review this
for the way i skirted around talking
about your marriage
[Music]
whose lawyers is she referring to there
i believe these are amber's regular
advisors
or
who
were involved in the
um
review negotiation of the mda between
amber and johnny depp and then if you uh
look at uh direct your attention to the
top
email from jess jess to um jessica
white's to
amber heard
she says to amber apologies for the
delay but we have needed to pass this
through quite a few lawyers
what lawyers did uh
jessica white's pass these through
passed the op-ed through
these were lawyers in the women's rights
project of the aclu plus
the director of the center for liberty
the deputy legal director of the aclu
who runs the center for liberty within
which is the
women's rights project and even the
legal director of the aclu who runs the
whole legal department our programmatic
litigation work on behalf of civil
liberties david cole
but it never got to your level correct
well david cole is at my level just to
be clear he also reports to the
executive director but it never got to
me or anybody on my team no one asked
you to review the first draft of the
op-ed
no
did anybody ever ask you to review any
drafts of the op-ed including the final
draft that was published in the
washington post
no
she says i want to make sure nothing was
said in here that puts you in jeopardy
with your nda what does that refer to
the uh non-disclosure agreement that was
entered into between deaf and hurt in
connection with the dissolution of their
marriage and the settlement agreement
[Music]
okay and is this a document that was
prepared in the ordinary course of the
aclu's business
yes was it kept in the ordinary course
of the aclu's business
yes
all right let's move please to uh
exhibit 37. have you ever seen exhibit
37 before yes
what is it
this is um a
draft of
the op-ed
that robin is sending to amber
after
a
conversation that they had
to discuss
the issues
in the op-ed
and in particular
um
my
yeah
to have a conversation about the op-ed
and um
and then she sends her changes that were
made to the op-ed
that were relating to
things that robin
and amber discussed during that meeting
and to be clear um
this next draft of the op-ed
reflects changes that robin schulman
made after she met in person with amber
heard is that correct
correct
what did miss shulman and ms hurd
discuss
during their in-person meeting
my understanding is that they discussed
some of the
personal experiences of
that amber heard has had that
uh were
that robin used to incorporate into
the op-ed
and isn't it true that miss heard's
advisers initially revised the draft to
remove
any reference
to ms herd's marriage or divorce i
recall a number of email communications
back and forth among
aclu personnel and ms heard's
attorneys
where they were
suggesting edits to the op-ed relating
to
matters covered in the mda
and then is it also true that there were
some
at the aclu
[Music]
who expressed their belief
that excising those references to
her marriage
and divorce
from johnny depp
made
the op-ed less impactful correct um it
is correct that is correct
but ultimately based on those voices
ms heard pushed to get
that excise material backed into the
op-ed so it could be more impactful true
that's not my understanding my
understanding is that the language that
wound up in the final op-ed piece was
very different from the original
language that robin included in the
op-ed
after
having
uh
spoken with amber about her personal
experiences and how was it different
um it was it
did not refer directly to
um ms heard's relationship with um with
johnny depp
okay let's move ahead please to exhibit
38.
it's our standby
[Music]
mr daugherty have you ever seen this
document before
yes
did is this one of the documents you
reviewed in preparation for your
deposition
yes
what does this relate to
so this relates to
stacy sullivan who reported to terry
tang
um
and her role with respect to this op-ed
piece was
to
think about the best place to place it
and to make the contacts
with the media in order to get it
placed and she suggests here uh
that the outlets that
the aclu and ms heard was considering
were the new york times the washington
post
team vogue and usa today is that correct
so not
uh stacy but jerry who i think you said
she jerry is a he and jerry um wrote
some suggested places to place this
after having had conversations um with
amber
and jerry's suggestions for the new york
times washington post team vogue or usa
today is that correct correct whose
responsibility was to place the op-ed
was it the aclu's miss herds or some
combination of the two
um the work would to place the op-ed was
taken on by um the aclu um in that we
have in our communications department
people with expertise and who regularly
do just that kind of work but as we can
see from this email it was done in
consultation with amber heard
and mr johnson writes
since the draft turned out pretty strong
and aquaman slated to do large numbers
i'm wondering what you think about it
what is what is what does he mean by
saying the draft turned out pretty
strong
this appears to be the analysis of
how um broad-based um and how
what kind of reach the media outlets
where we can place this will have and
that media outlets are more likely to
um to take on publishing
an op-ed like this
if it is a strong one
and
um if it is
and and to the extent that it is written
by a public a person as a an entertainer
a well-known person um
that
the the more they are in the public eye
at the time the more likely
um
it will be accepted by a more prominent
or broader reach media outlet and so
that's the sort of descending
um
uh media outlets are in descending terms
in terms of descending um you know
likelihood of
uh
well descending importance and reach but
greater likelihood um from you know for
example uh as we go down members
referencing her own direct personal
experience
and her marriage to johnny depp
makes it a stronger product correct i
think that um the
amber's um
contributions to
the you know
the the portion of the op-ed that talks
about personal experiences is part of
what um
uh informed the
view that this was a strong op-ed and
the importance of the
women's rights issues referred to
in the op-ed in that some of them were
very timely women's rights issues
before congress
and
ms heard
had a co-starring role in aquaman
correct
i don't know whether she was a co-star
but i know that that was a film that she
was in
and didn't she tell the aclu that she
wanted the op-ed to come out
just after aquaman was released
i do recall that there was a
conversation about the optimal timing
for the op-ed piece
and as part of that conversation
ms heard said in words or substance that
she wanted the op-ed to come out
soon after aquaman correct i believe
that's correct
who did she uh
relate that to i don't recall although i
believe that there's documents that we
produce that can shed some light on that
is exhibit 38 kept
in the ordinary course of the aclu's
business
yes
was it prepared by
people with knowledge and preparedness
temporaneous manner
yes it was
and it was made in the ordinary course
of the aclu's business true
true okay if we could move ahead please
to exhibit 41.
this is another one of these uh well
it's not that long yes sir standby
uh mr daugherty have you ever seen this
document before
yes
what is it
these are further communications
among
employees staff members in the
development department
regarding
amber's
the placement of amber's ad
and the finalization of the op-ed piece
not adam sorry op-ed and the
finalization of it
right and if we could move ahead please
to aclu 257
and specifically the email from robin
shulman to jessica wheats
on december 11th continuing on to the
next
or strike that let's go to the email on
the last line jessica white's email
she says team time stamp because
what's the time stamp on the email that
you're referring to uh i'm sorry this is
december 11th email at 11 05 a.m okay um
jessica weeks
you see that
okay and she says amber sent back the
op-ed with final edits from her legal
team
which specifically neutered much of the
copy regarding her marriage and the
domestic violence do you see that
is that consistent with your
recollection i'm not sure about the use
of the term neutered here um but i do
know that her lawyers
removed references to
her marriage and divorce
and then she writes the goal is to get
this out this week to capitalize on the
tremendous campaign for aquaman
what does that mean
that means
from the aclu's perspective that amber
is about to receive an incredible amount
of press and be in the public eye so
what what better a time would it be than
now
to
put out this op-ed so that it generates
significant readership about our issues
and amber agreed with the aclu on that
point correct i believe the answer is
yes every step of the way we were um
making these decisions with um amber's
pr
representatives involved
okay let's move back to um
an email in the middle of 257 okay
and uh it is from jessica wheat's uh
time stamped 11 09 a.m on december 11
2018.
okay
robin her lawyers omitted the below but
amber would love to see a way to have
that part in bold somehow put back in is
there an artful way to do that otherwise
she is okay with the final uh two years
ago i sought a temporary restraining
order from my then husband ellipses was
changed to two years ago after
successfully acquiring a temporary
restraining order but still not cleared
by her lawyers do you see that i do
was that uh consistent with your
understanding about what ms heard's
desires were
yeah i trust jessica white's
relationship with amber so that when
jessica told robin that that was
something amber wanted i have no reason
to think that that's not correct
okay and finally let's look at the
beginning um
the first email exhibit 41
from stacy sullivan to jessica wheats
says
yes and i need to read the latest
version and robin told me amber's
lawyers took out some of the stuff that
made it really powerful
so let me look to see if i think it's
strong enough for top tier
um what did she mean by top tier i think
from stacy's perspective the more
powerful a document is the more likely
it will go into a top-tier
news outlet such as the new york times
or the washington post you know that
sort of descending
tiering that was in jerry johnson's
email
okay
and is exhibit 41 kept in the ordinary
course of the aclu's business
yes was it prepared in the ordinary
course of the aclu's business by people
having knowledge and done so
contemporaneously
yes okay thank you let's move ahead to
43.
standby
okay um
directing your attention to
the first page in exhibit 43
from jessica weeds to sean waltz who is
sean walsh
um
shawn walsh at www.com
i don't know who that is um this is an
email that includes
in it
people
other than aclu employees and aclu
consultants so i'm assuming it's
somebody relating to um you know one of
amber's representatives but i don't know
for sure
do you know who eric george is
yeah george bgr firm yes eric george was
one of amber's attorneys
and she's announcing to the group that
it's going to the washington post a
triple exclamation points
correct
take it the aclu was pleased that it was
placed in the washington post
correct
and i believe you testified earlier but
i just want to confirm for the record
the aclu
uh took on the responsibility of
attempting to place the op-ed correct
correct
and why the aclu instead of amber or her
pr team
placing
op-eds
about
matters such as this is the kind of
thing that is the bread and butter for
the aclu and so
um i don't recall if conversation
happened about whether her pr people or
rpr people should place uh should
be in the ones that
do the work to place this but it is
fully consistent with how we do our work
that we
place this one
all right let's go back to exhibit 42 if
you don't mind
yes sir standby
have you ever seen this document before
mr daugherty i am um familiar with this
document
uh is this one of the documents you
reviewed in preparation for this
deposition today
yes
was it made in the ordinary course of
aclu's business by people having
knowledge and doing so
contemporaneously
correct yes was it maintained by the
aclu in the ordinary course of business
yes
would you please direct your attention
sir to
page bates number 1181
in the middle of the page purports to be
an email from stacy sullivan
michael larabee
and others at the washington well i'll
just say michael larabee who is michael
larabee
um
michael larabee
appears to be a person who is a contact
that stacy sullivan had at the
washington post
and so she sent
she reached out to him first
about placing the ad
and then
because she received a bounce back out
of office from mike larabee
she sent
the um
her original request to michael duffy
and mark laswell also at washington post
and what was the purpose of her sending
them this email this was her attempt to
get the op-ed placed
and she writes hey michael wondering if
we might interest you in a piece by
amber heard
who as you may recall was beaten up
during her brief marriage to johnny depp
on what the incoming congress can do to
help protect women in similar situations
did i read that correctly yes you read
it correctly
all right let's look please let's turn
to
exhibit 73.
standby
dougherty have you ever seen this
document before
yes
is this
the online copy of the op-ed that the
aclu
placed
yes
directing your attention to the title
amber heard
colon i spoke up against sexual violence
and faced our culture's wrath
that has to change
who
came up with that title
based on my investigation i'm not aware
of any um any uh
i'm not aware that the aclu had any role
in um
writing the name of the op-ed piece and
my understanding of how op-ed pieces
work is that it is the
um
the in the the the media so in this case
the washington post would have drafted
the um the name of the the title of the
op-ed and not and not the person who
wrote the op-ed did the washington post
uh seek the aclu's or miss herds
approval of its title
i believe the answer to that is no
there's nothing in the evidence that
shows that they reached out to us to do
that and it is inconsistent with my
understanding in that they do these news
outlets do not usually ask for the
permission um of the author of the op-ed
to um for you know for when they come up
with the title hello mr dougherty would
you please or would the technician
please call up exhibit 45.
yes sir standby
yes
mr dougherty have you ever seen um
plaintiff's exhibit 45 which is bates
number aclu 623
um
hold on i'm just making it a little
bigger
okay yes um i have seen this document
and is this one of the documents you
reviewed in preparation for your
deposition
that's correct and what is it
this is an article
that um
was in us today
and
um
ties
amber's statements in her op-ed piece to
johnny depp
and when jessica white says
so much
for not mentioning jd
what did she mean
i speculate that she was
saying that
there were significant efforts made by
amber's attorneys to take out the
references um to
johnny depp in her marriage um
and
yet nonetheless
people made that connection
and in particular the
reporter for the usa today
took her
to be referring to johnny depp when she
spoke of being the victim of domestic
violence correct
correct is this was this document
prepared in the ordinary course of the
aclu's business uh contemporaneously
about people having knowledge
yes it was it maintained by the aclu in
the ordinary course of business yes
and would you please move ahead now to
exhibit 46.
yes sir stand by
go
mr doherty have you ever seen exhibit 46
which is aclu
baits number 12
87
yes
what is it
this is a um
statement by robin shulman saying that
um
that
the
article that they're referring to
basically um
you know
recasts everything that is said but but
ties it to johnny depp
so ms shulman is agreeing with mrs
white's characterization
that uh the usa took mr ms hurd to be
referring to
[Music]
her allegations of physical violence by
johnny depp correct
yes
and she says it's kind of amazing that
they just grabbed the entire op-ed and
rewrote it using johnny's name why was
it amazing i don't know why she found it
amazing
because that was consistent with your
understanding she was referring at least
in part to johnny depp correct
based on my review of prior drafts of
the op-ed i knew that there were um that
that she was referring to johnny depp in
her marriage physics was exhibit 46
prepared in the ordinary course of
business uh by people having knowledge
contemporaneously yes
was it maintained in the ordinary course
of the aclu's business
yes
okay let's move to exhibit 59 please
which is bates numbers
aclu 2614
through
2616.
okay
have you ever seen this document
before um
scrolling to the beginning
yes
and what is it
this is a
conversation
among aclu employees
regarding what were the
amounts contributed to the aclu that
were
connected to our relationship with ms
heard
and is this exhibit 59 kept in the
ordinary course of the aclu's business
um
yes and it was prepared
contemporaneously by people with
knowledge in the ordinary courts of the
aclu business correct
correct
and looking at the um chart
on aclu 2615
this is the same contributions chart
that you testified about earlier from
salesforce correct
correct
and again
as in the prior exhibit
this chart or ledger does not reflect
the hundred thousand dollar contribution
from
johnny depp in amber heard's name in
august of
2016. correct
correct and you still can't account for
why that wouldn't have been included
we
assumed that there was um an error made
and not
including that in ms heard's account
uh you know the where we keep the
records of her
in salesforce um although anthony as you
see then raised the very question what
about the hundred thousand dollars
and directing your attention to the
first page in this exhibit
do you see
the email from mr romero to mr maresco
subject a quick question
mr romero asked did elon's other gifts
come from vanguard
what does that refer
my personal knowledge is that anthony
was just asking whether um
other
gifts from elon musk had been issued
from recommendations he made to vanguard
regarding his
donor advice funded vanguard and mr
maresco then responds
one of them yes his five million dollar
gift in february 2017
was from vanguard do you see that
i see it
and if you look at the next page
vanguard was the same entity
that made the
soft credit contribution
in amber herd's name to the tune of five
hundred thousand dollars correct
correct
and he says in any case my understanding
was that the five hundred thousand
dollars from vanguard was recommended by
e em do you see that
yes
and em stands for elon musk correct
correct
and also in that email above that
uh mr moreskos
[Music]
states that
mr musk's one million dollar gift in may
2018
was from fidelity do you see that
yes he must have either that means
a separate donor advice fund he has a
fidelity or
from
fidelity um
you know
in direct investment accounts he has a
fidelity i'm assuming the former but i
don't know
and if you look at the next page in uh
the salesforce chart
the second payment
credited to
ms heard
for 350 000
as of
december 11 2018
came from
that same fidelity correct i don't know
the answer to that question i know that
um it came
from
a fidelity
donor advised fund the 350 thousand
dollars but i don't know if it is
elon musk's donor advised funded at
fidelity
but it could be
it could be
okay let's move thank you uh on to uh 61
please which is bates number aclu 1669
through 71.
i'm directing your attention to the last
email in this exhibit from
jill sargent
to inga
sardis sorensen and tyler richard who
were
sorensen and tyler richard
um inga
and tyler are both um
senior communications department
strategists in our communications
department okay
and miss sergeant from reuters asked i'm
preparing some material while awaiting a
verdict in the johnny depp libel trial
in london
and wanted to fact check amber heard's
current previous links with the aclu
do you recall that ms mr depp's uh
definite that this is a reference to mr
depp's defamation case in the uk against
the sun
it appears to me that that's the that's
the trial she's referring to okay
directing your attention please to
page number aclu 1670
the email from jessica white's
to tyler richards
do you see where miss white's rights
the answer is yes she's still an
ambassador that's a reference to ms hurd
still being an aclu ambassador correct
correct
and miss whites writes quote
she donated her full settlement to
charity
50 to the aclu and 50 to another
organization
that's a reference to
ms hurd's representation
that she donated the full amount of her
divorce settlement from johnny depp to
tr to uh charity correct correct
and that statement was not true
uh she had not donated the full amount
of her settlement
seven million dollars to the aclu
or the children's hospital of los
angeles correct at the time that jess
whites wrote this in july of 2020 miss
miss hurt had not donated her full
settlement to the to the aclu and i'm
not aware of what she did to the other
organization at the time miss whites
wrote that the the aclu was still 2.2
million dollars short even if you credit
ms heard with 100 000 that johnny depp
gave to the aclu correct at the time
that she wrote this there
we have received the
1.3 so yes 2.2
million of the full 3.5 million we had
not received was 60 exhibit 61 kept in
the ordinary course of the aclu's
business
yes
was it prepared in the ordinary course
of the business by people having
knowledge contemporaneously yes
okay let's move to exhibit 62 please
have you seen this document before
yes
what is it
this is um
jessica white's reaching out to the
communications department
in order to
come up with a correct
statement that we could make in response
to the reuters article
and she comes up with recommended
language on this
um that she then wants to confirm
with our development department
so she is doing diligence to ensure that
anything we say to the media is going to
be
correct
um
uh let's move ahead to exhibit 63.
do you have that in front of you
i'm just making it larger right now it
just arrived
you ever seen this document before
yes
what is it this is um
back and forth between richard tyler in
the communications department
jessica white and another communications
department junior
person ava lopez
and it all concerns
what we can say
to
what we should say to um
reuters in response to their question
about amber and her contributions to the
aclu
and this was prepared in the ordinary
course of the acl youth business correct
correct and it was
[Music]
prepared and maintained in the ordinary
course of the acl youth business true
true correct
let's look uh at the second page of the
exhibit
an email from tyler richard to jessica
white's
who is tyler richard
it's richard tyler and he uh and
no it's tyler richard that's right tyler
richard and he is a senior person in our
communications department
uh and mr richard says amber heard is an
aclu ambassador for women's rights since
2018
she has she also pledged her full
settlement to charity do you see that i
do um
and miss white's response yeah i think
that's safer
i had nightmares about this last night
i'm very upset do you think this is okay
why was ms white so upset
about the characterization
of miss hurt's charitable donations or
lack thereof
my understanding is that as a
communications department professional
um jessica was um concerned about these
um
news articles that were appearing and
what impact they would have on um you
know the the
how the aclu and his work with amber has
seen
she was concerned that the aclu was not
telling the truth
about
amber's paying the 3.5 million correct
i don't see it that way i see it as her
doing everything she can in order to
produce a correct statement to the press
wouldn't the correct statement to the
press
be uh that she's short 2.3 million
dollars as i testified earlier that's
not the kind of thing that we would ever
say about a donor to the aclu instead we
would um especially when it isn't the
fact that there was any specific time
period by which we were supposed to have
received um you know any specific amount
of money um considering that she didn't
plot sign the pledge agreement and
therefore um
you know
there's an attempt
so as an organization we attempt to work
with our donors who are having financial
difficulties in order receive um you
know
the funding from them that they want to
give to us so no i don't see this i
don't know we would in that sort of
scenario we would never say she's short
anything
um directing your attention to the email
um
at
bates number aclu 1700
okay from
miss whites to mr richard uh dated july
31
she says
i'm just stressed about her
and the difficulties with all this
who is her assume that is
amber heard
why was miss white's stressed about
amber heard because this is a stressful
thing to have
these kinds of news reports out there um
and in particular about an aclu
ambassador
what kind of news reports are you
referring to
what i believe the reuters article um
from the the reuters article
and what did the news article say that
was distressing i think it was it was
the um tie between um the attempts to
make ms heard
um uh
look poorly in the press regarding her
donations
did you talk to ms white's in
preparation for this deposition
yes i did what did she tell you about
the donations and and how she was
stressed about miss hurt
um ms white's um didn't say anything
specific about that
you didn't ask her about why she said
she was stressed about amber hurd and
the difficulties with all this i
believed in reviewing the documents that
i had an understanding of why this was a
difficult situation for
um many people
so the answer is you didn't ask her
about that did you i did not ask her
that question we'll have to uh did you
ask her about the nightmares she had
about amber heard and why she had what
what the substance of her nightmares
were about amber heard no i did not
honor uh counsel for miss heard is now
taking over the question all right thank
you
exhibit number one this is
it was introduced as well uh by uh
by council for mr depp but it's easier
for me to just jump into this one do you
recognize this document
um yes it says here
and i described your plan to donate 3.5
million to aclu
over the next 10 years as you very much
believe in what they are doing
now the way in which donate is used here
how would you interpret that i would say
that at the very least it is expressing
an intention to um make that donation
and by the term plan
okay
and
would you distinguish between donate and
pledge given the reference to the next
10 years
about elon musk's intention i would read
this to um
mean that to that that it
that it isn't clear whether this is a
intended to be a pledge a legally
binding pledge to create a receivable
this is something that i would want to
um what i would i would hope would be a
legally binding pledge but i wouldn't
necessarily say that this was
right
and the term donate here
how would you interpret that based on
the description you gave a little
earlier i would take donate to mean
contributions from ms heard
what if any uh interpretation would you
have that this also meant pledge
so so two things in response to your
question one is um
plan to donate when i said it would come
from his ms heard i would think that
that would be either miss her directly
or from a donor advice fund that she um
has set up and would recommend um but um
over the next 10 years makes me think
that um
you know donate could theoretically be a
pledge but um but that's something that
we would want to um
to attempt to confirm
and just so i understand
what's the difference between donate and
pledge and how you are interpreting this
if this used the word pledge instead i
would have more assurance that this was
intended to be a um uh you know
a hard and fast promise that even could
potentially be a legally binding process
i promise
i'm going to show you what has been
marked as defendant's exhibit number two
um
do you recognize this document debates
2632
i do recognize this document
and what is your understanding of what
it says
that this is the cover letter to which
the check for 100 000
um was attached um which related to
johnny depp's contribution to the aclu
in the name of amber hurd
now you've used the term binding a few
times here in responding to these
what is your distinction
with the words pledge and donate
that relates specifically to binding
a pledge is
if if something is legally binding it is
the pledge but it doesn't necessarily
mean that everybody that uses the term
pledge means something that's legally
binding donated is a much much broader
term
and donate can mean pledge
yeah i think that the word donate can be
used in connection with um with a pledge
do you have any understanding
of what amber
occurred
believed was a pledge versus a donation
i don't know did the aclu have any
reason to believe that amber heard would
not pay the aclu
3.5 million dollars i think that
everybody at the aclu was um uh was
hoping we were hope the aclu was hoping
and expecting that the full 3.5 million
would be paid to the aclu the fact that
the pledge form wasn't signed um
was um you know cast some
potential doubt on that and then
um once ms heard began having financial
difficulties um we obviously
recognized that that might um impact
whether
the full 3.5 million is paid or impact
whether it's paid over a much longer
period of time in some intermittent way
do you have any evidence to suggest that
amber heard
still does not intend to pay the aclu
the full 3.5 million
i have no based on my investigation i'm
not aware of any um indication that miss
hurt has decided to no longer pay
additional amounts to the aclu i'm going
to ask you to bring up number four
please
i'm going to ask you to take a look at
this document and it starts out on the
bottom with amber on october 17 2016
to
arp who's that
that's anthony romero's private email
anthony romero private all right and
she's telling him to go ahead
and it's all ready to cash mr depp's
check do you see that
i do
and then mr romero responds to her says
thank you for the response we will
capture check but that means you have
quote over paid for this year
as you wired 350 000 and then 100 000
from mists of debt so you can keep track
that where you are on the overall
amounts do you see that
i do
i'm going to show you what has been
marked as deposition
defendants exhibit number 14
and it's base stamp aclu 2588-89
this is
and i realized there was a version of
this that mr
chu showed you but
this includes an email from mr romero to
jonathan maresco
and then mr maresco to
mr romero with a copy to mike weir
and it says here hi anthony if you get a
chance on sunday can you please check in
with amber on her next pledge payment
she has a balance of 2.55 million on her
350 000 10-year pledge
below is a summary of her other payments
do you see that
i do
okay and so this has the 500
500
and the three hundred and fifty thousand
and the one hundred thousand on it
correct
correct okay and that was september 28
2018.
i'm going to show you what has been
marked as defendant's exhibit number 15.
it's base stamp 2595 and i'm going to
make it larger
and
if i can show you we have an email from
mr romero
and is there anything i can do to help
facilitate a pledge payment of 350 000
and it's dated november 27 2018. do you
see that
i do
all right and then amber comes back on
11 29 and says hang on i'll be right
with you
you see that correct yeah i see it
okay and then the 350 000 dollar payment
came in
on december 11 2018 correct correct
all right and that made it the total of
what 1.3 million we've decided right
what was the total amount of the
donations after the 12
11 2018 that were made towards miss
heard's 3.5 million dollar pledge to
aclu 1.3 million all right now if ms
herb had just given 350 000 each year
what would the amount have been as of
december 2018
one million five five uh fifty
it would be 350
three
350
fifty thousand so
that's nine
uh
one million fifty thousand okay and so
she was effectively 250 000 ahead of
that as of december 2018 correct
subjects after mr depp filed suit
against amber heard on march 1 2019
what if any payments did miss heard make
to the aclu
towards her 2.5 million dollar pledge
no additional payments
no this was also shown to you by mr chu
and one of his documents i'm just it's
it's aclu document
7 the 2 12 11 2018 350 000 designation
donation from amber heard anonymous do
you see that
i do now the aclu continues
to recognize amber heard as an
ambassador for the aclu is that correct
we do she and she continues to be listed
on our website
a donor
deduct
a donation before they actually make the
payment to the aclu
no
yeah a deduction cannot be taken prior
to when the deduction is made a
deduction is taken with respect to a tax
year so the deduction would have to be
made within a tax here in order for it
to be um
deducted that year
okay
now you also were
testified earlier
about different sources
of donations and you said
um
that
someone can make a donation
in honor to fulfill someone else's
pledge do you recall that testimony
a person can make a donor
in honor of someone else um and when i
said in honor of a person i was more
referring to you know in memory of a
person or in honor of you know
um a new executive director of an
organization people make donations in
honor of them but a person certainly can
make a gift and say that i would like to
make this gift to the organization
because i know that this other person
has
committed something to the organization
and i i'd like to pay that amount
a person can do that
now was it your understanding
with the letter from mr white that mr
depp was making a 100 000
payment
on behalf of amber heard towards her 3.5
million dollar pledge
yes that that gift from um was in
connection with um the amounts that
amber had said that she wanted to
contribute to the organization all right
and and it's been your testimony i think
that there was an error in not including
that in your sales force is that correct
correct okay now is it also your
understanding that elon musk made the
500 000
uh payment towards amber kurds 3.5
million dollar pledge
um yes we don't know that with absolute
certainty but that is our organization's
understanding okay and you credit it
towards chris herd's pledge correct
yes
does it matter to the aclu
where it comes from if it's tagged and
said
it's it's as part of this this person's
pledge we're always happy to receive
funds um
from donors and if a donor is unable to
make a contribution of an amount that
they said they intended to make if
they're able to have someone else make a
contribution to the organization that's
completely fine by us
it's still it's still more money to aclu
correct correct and it's towards a
pledge that you're hoping you can count
on correct
toward a pledge in the weak form of it
which is that somebody's making an
intention it can it would not be able to
be unsatisfied in connection with a
legally binding pledge
well you did credit the 500 000 towards
amber heard's pledge correct yes we did
and although you didn't initially credit
the hundred thousand dollar payment by
mr deb
towards her pledge you agree that that
should have been credited towards amber
heard's pledge as well correct correct
now we saw a document that mr chu
showed you a short while ago that
indicated that elon musk made some other
significant
contributions including one million
dollars and five million dollars that
were separate and apart from the five
hundred thousand correct
is that right okay
now mr mr
asked you if uh the aclu benefited from
the fact that amber heard
pledged or donated the 3.5 million
and i think your answer was that you
benefit you know whenever there's
donations made and the publicity
associated with it
what if any benefit would the aclu have
had
if amber heard
pledged or donated 1.3 million as
opposed to 3.5 million if i understand
your question correctly i think that it
is always a positive thing
to report on
donations made to the aclu mr dougherty
you testified
to a number of documents about the op-ed
and the back-and-forths with the
attorneys and everything else
are you aware of any evidence at any
stage
of the op-ed
drafts through publication that amber
heard did not rely on her counsel's
advice
from what i know
is her
involved her attorneys
and made changes to the op-ed based on
the advice of her attorneys
and so my question is are you aware any
evidence
that would suggest that amber heard did
not rely on the advice of her attorneys
based on my investigation i'm not aware
of a situation where she did not rely on
her terms
thank you
and
i'm going to make a reference to their
exhibit number 31 this is uh
it's just called exhibit 31 and mr two
put it again jerry johnson was writing
an email and he listed a number of
topics
with your understanding that the aclu
shows a number of those topics of course
subject to amber's approval but it was
their idea on some of these issues
to address in the op-ed my understanding
is that those were um aclu issues that
jerry johnson came up with that might
have been
issues that could be covered in the
op-ed
all right
i assume
for your next witness as a remote
witness correct and i assume it'll take
longer than 30 minutes is that a good
fair assumption yes that's right your
honor yeah i think it'll take a little
longer than 30.
all right i think what i'd propose then
ladies and gentlemen uh what i might
have you do is take an extended lunch
until 2 30 because i have an obligation
at 2.
um so
then what that means though that we
would go through till 5 30 tonight is
that agreeable with everybody on the
jury is that agreeable with everybody
here all right let's go ahead and do
that then go ahead let's go ahead and
give you a lunch break until 2 30. okay
just do not discuss the case and do not
do any outside research okay thank you
all right so be in recess till two okay
all right thank you
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
oh
all right thank you ladies and gentlemen
are your next witness
yes your honor plaintiff calls edward
white okay thank you
penalty of law
yes
afternoon sir
good afternoon mr white
good afternoon counselor
will you state your name full name for
the record
yes edward white
where do you reside
los angeles california
how are you employed
many years ago i founded edward white
and company certified public accountants
and i am the managing and senior partner
of the firm
what is a certified public accounting
firm
a certified public accounting firm is
authorized
by particular state in my case
california
to audit financial information and to
certify
the statements related there too
what's the nature of the work that's
done at edward white and company
it's diversified
it includes providing uh
tax and related compliance services that
is to do the tax returns for the clients
that's both fiduciary corporate
individual as well as partnership work
we also are involved in providing
financial statements for financial
institutions
and for governmental agencies
we in addition to that have a business
management department and provide a wide
variety of services in that capacity
are you the edward white of edward white
and company yes i am
who do you employ
we employ a very talented group of
professionals
that have really amazing credentials
they have graduate degrees from nyu and
usc in business administration as well
as taxation
many of my colleagues have been with the
firm for over 25 years in one case for
35 years i'm very proud to be associated
with this group of people
who are your principal clients
we represent approximately 100 high net
worth individuals and the companies that
they own and operate
in addition to that we do work for
governmental agencies such as the
department of justice
the state of alaska the state of
california and the city of long beach
what's your educational background
i started my college career
utilizing the
gi bill i served four years in the air
force and was fortunate enough to have
that opportunity
my undergraduate degree was in business
administration
and i have a master's degree in business
administration from the university of
southern california
after completing my
graduate degree at usc i studied
several i took several tax classes
corporate fiduciary estate and gift
and
subject matters such as that
do you have any other experience with
education
yes i was a former professor of
accounting and taxation
at california state university located
in los angeles california
what kind of work do you personally do
the work i do is primarily transaction
oriented
acquisitions of companies dispositions
that is buying or selling a company
arranging financing with
large financial institutions
consulting with clients where they feel
it's appropriate for me to be involved
uh assisting my colleagues as i
mentioned to you we have approximately
100 high net worth individual clients
and there's always something that that i
can contribute to
do you hold any certifications
yes i'm certified in financial forensics
by the american institute of certified
public accountants
i'm also
a member of the american institute of
certified public accounts and the
california society of certified public
accountants and of course i'm a
certified public accountant
what are financial forensics
that's an attempt to ascertain not only
the facts but what transpired
as it relates to financial activity so
you do a study based upon financial
records you then look at contracts
you look at other financial information
in an attempt to
once again not only ascertain what the
results were but what caused the results
have you ever previously testified in
court
yes i've been accepted as an expert
witness in both the california court and
the federal courts
and i have testified
in matters involving the department of
justice and the fbi
okay
do you serve on any boards or have you
served on any boards
objection relevance your honor this
witness is not being proffered as an
expert in this case all right wasn't
this just a fact witness and not an
expert would you effect witness and it
goes to credibility i'll sustain the
objection i think we can move on okay
do you know mr depp
yes i do how did you come to know mr
depp
i met him because he was introduced to
me by a senior executive at the bank of
california richard smith
do you work with mr depp
yes i do in what capacity we are his
business management firm
how long have you served in that
capacity by approximately six years
what does that role involve
processing managing his financial
affairs
as you know mr deb is an amazing talent
internationally acclaimed for his work
but he relegated his financial
activities to me and my colleagues so we
provide a wide variety of services for
him
do you do this kind of work for other
people
yes we do
numerous other clients
when did you first become involved with
mr deb
approximately six years ago after the
introduction from mr smith
what was the nature of the work that you
were
that you were to perform for him
initially it was to perform a forensic
study
evaluate his financial affairs and to
formulate recommendations on how he
could manage his affairs in a more
advantageous manner
after you conducted
that analysis what did you do i met with
mr deb the purpose of which was to share
with him
uh the results of our findings and to
make recommendations in how he could
resolve the issues he was confronting
when was that meeting
that meeting was on april 21st 2016.
who called the meeting i did i called
the meeting because i felt it was
appropriate to meet with mr deb
and to discuss his affairs
and to provide him with
opportunities and plans
and strategies to resolve the issues he
was confronting
where was the meeting held it was held
at his offices
in los angeles california
do you know approximately what time it
began it began at approximately 7 30
and my recollection is there were seven
people in attendance
including mr deb and myself
was alcohol served at the meeting not to
my recollection i don't recall any
alcohol being consumed
did mr depp stay for the entirety of the
meeting oh yes he was very interested in
the contents he asked very thoughtful
questions
um he was fully engaged
and fully sensitive to the matters that
we were discussing
did there come a time when mr
mr depp didn't participate in the
meeting
no he was very actively involved he did
excuse himself on two or three occasions
it's my understanding that he was going
to contact miss heard
and attempt to respond to her concerns
and also address the fact that this was
an extremely important meeting
and that involved his financial
viability and that he felt it imperative
to stay and address the issues i was
discussing with him
when did the meeting conclude
at approximately 9 30.
so it went for approximately two hours
at the conclusion of the meeting
what did you deserve what did you
observe as to mr depp
um that he was fully engaged once again
he thanked me profusely for not only
addressing their problems
but he was excited about the fact that
was a strategy and plan to resolve the
problems
did he appear impaired to you in any way
no to the contrary
i found him to be i'm sorry sir there
was an objection all right what was the
objection i'm sorry
leading
just
i've asked him for his observation as
well
well if you want to ask different i'll
sustain that objection but you can ask
another question did you make any
observations as to mr
uh
depp's potential impairment
it was readily apparent to me
that he was actively involved in the
conversation he asked very thoughtful
and prudent questions
he was genuinely interested and once
again when he left he thanked me
profusely for not only addressing the
issues but formulating a strategy and
plan to resolve them in a successful
manner
did you have
did you play any role
on mr deaf's behalf with respect to the
dissolution
of his marriage to misheard
yes i was actively involved in
negotiations of the uh separation and
the marriage dissolve
what role did you play in those
negotiations
well in my capacity as his business
manager i understood his financial
capacity
and the tax implications associated with
it
so i was actively involved
in addressing
those issues as they were forthcoming
from council
you mentioned tax implications what are
you talking about there
excuse me do you think you may just
mention tax implications what are you
talking about there well what i was
talking about is that
when
miss heard began the negotiations
she was asking for approximately four
million dollars
that
balance then was increased hearsay
black foundation hearsay
these are requests made by ms hurdler
council
in a conversation in communications
as a result
of your
involvement
on behalf of mr def in the negotiation
what was your understanding of what ms
heard was looking for
she initially was looking for a
consideration of four million dollars
but a demand continually increased
it went from four million dollars to
five million dollars
then it went from five million dollars
to five and a half million dollars
then it went to seven million dollars
and then
it was seven million dollars and she
required demanded that mr deb also pay
500 000 to her attorneys
then
after
that consideration
she also said that all the community
liabilities
that were accumulated during the course
of the marriage which
sorry there's no objection sir whatever
this objection i'm sorry if you can't
hear it i'll let you know okay thank you
and no problem goes into his allegations
of what she said which your honor just
struck and
sustain the objection on that he has no
foundation to suggest that no knowledge
of that governor
i understand that
i asked his understanding all right i'll
overrule the objection go ahead
may i continue
she'll tell you yes yes go ahead yes
he learns very well
so the next demand
was that all the community liabilities
that were unresolved approximately 13.5
million dollars
that mr depp had to pay those
liabilities in its entirety
so at that point
she was demanding 14 million 250 000
of consideration
and then it got worse
the next demand
was that all of this consideration
be paid to her free of taxation
and counselor for him to pay 14 million
14 million hundred and fifty thousand
dollars to misheard
that would require him
to earn approximately thirty million
dollars so far beyond the scope so far
beyond his foundation of what was
discussed all right i'll sustain that
last last answer all right
next
question did you make a proposal as to
how payments would be made to misheard
yes i did and they were initially
contemplated to be paid directly to the
charities
the children's hospital los angeles for
the benefit of the children who required
severe medical service and to the aclu
during the course of the negotiations
one of the demands because the contract
changed was that the payments be made
directly to ms heard
did you have
any personal
uh involvement with either the aclu or
the children's hospital yes i did what
was that uh
mr depp directed me
to issue two one hundred thousand dollar
checks
directly to the children's hospital los
angeles i knew that he was involved and
supported their efforts
and appreciated his service in addition
to that he directed me to contribute one
hundred thousand dollars to aclu
in accordance with his instructions my
colleagues drafted the checks i executed
them and they were delivered to the two
charities
did you
continue making payments to either of
those charities on ms heard's behalf
no in fact i was chastised for making
the payments by ms heard's counsel and
told that the payments in the future had
to go directly to her this is clear
hearsay he's not answering the question
i would i would ask for you to instruct
him to answer the question and not
expound upon his i'll sustain us to hear
you say next question
what role did you play
with respect to the payments ultimately
made to miss her
we
supplied the payments to ms heard
in accordance with the agreement
either on or before the date in which
they were required to be paid
the
first payments made to misheard was 2
million dollars in 2017.
then in april of 2017 another payment of
one million dollars made payable
directly to ms heard was made
then in august of 2017 another million
dollars was paid directly to ms hurt
then in november 500 000 dollars would
pay directly to miss herd
my colleagues drafted those checks i
executed they were delivered on a timely
basis
therefore in 2017
she was paid 4.5 million dollars
directly paid to her
then on february 1 of 2018
she was paid the final installment of
2.3 million dollars for total payments
that went directly to ms heard of 6.8
million dollars
do you know when this lawsuit was filed
yes it was filed in march 1 2019.
were the payments that were made on mr
depp's behalf uh directly to ms heard
the only economic benefit she received
jackson leading
i haven't heard though
go
i
i'll overrule the objection for some now
go ahead
were the payments made on uh
to misheard the only economic benefits
that you received from the settlement
agreement no as i shared with you
earlier
mr depp
was required to pay five hundred
thousand dollars to miss herd's council
which he did in a timely respectful
manner
he was also required to pay all the
community liabilities
which
accumulated during their 15-month
marriage
was approximately
13 million 500 000
so he paid all the community liabilities
she paid none of them that's why you
have to aggregate the money that was
paid directly to her
the money was paid to her to the
charities on her behalf the money was
paid to her attorneys and the relief of
all these liabilities that she had that
he had to satisfy that's why i said you
counselor that the total consideration
paid to her was 14 million 250 000
and she demanded that that payment be
made
free of taxation that mr depp would have
to satisfy all the tax liabilities
how long were they married for they were
married for 15 months
okay
um
were the payments that went to misheard
the only uh payments that you've made on
mr depp's behalf
no we satisfied all of his obligations
so it was very customary for us to pay
everything that mr depp was obligated to
pay
are you familiar with an entity known as
2020 wine merchants yes i am
what
why are you familiar with it it's a
prominent purveyor of wine in los
angeles foundation
hearsay
i don't see that hearsay but
foundation at this point
sure
all right
i think where we left off is i asked you
how were you familiar with 2020 wine
merchants and if that's not what i asked
you that's what i'm asking you now
2020 is a
highly recognized purveyor of wine in
los angeles along with other companies
what involvement if any did you have
with 2020
i satisfied the liabilities that mr deb
incurred
which at the
dissolve of their marriage was
approximately 160 thousand dollars
do you continue to pay mr depp's wine
bill
yes i do we pay all of his obligations
but his wine bill has shrunk to
virtually zero
um
because uh
he does not consume that much in the way
of wine he's made a few gifts around
christmas time
but his wine bill has gone to virtually
zero
are you familiar with a spanish wine
known as vega cecilia
yes
how are you familiar with that
i know that it is a very expensive wine
and that i know that miss heard enjoyed
drinking the wine
how much does it cost
the cost of the wine is approximately
500 a bottle
were you ultimately
charged with
paying for
the
wine that was served on
at the birthday party on april 21 2016
yes i was we read the payment foundation
i'll overrule the objection that's fine
how many bottles of vega
cecilia were served
at a miss herd's request
uh she ordered five bottles of the wine
and eight bottles of other wine so a
total of 13 bottles of wine
thank you mr white have no other
questions
this time cross examination
thank you your honor
good afternoon mr white good afternoon
counselor your firm has been paid
millions of dollars by mr depp and his
company since you were first retained in
2016 correct correct
and in fact you're being paid for the
time that you're sitting on that witness
stand today aren't you
no
well you've char you charged the time
that you spent
in connection with
legal proceedings in this case correct
that's correct but i charge for my time
yeah and i it's the same you answer my
questions in fact you charge 710 an hour
for your time don't you counsel if you
let me complete my answer i'm happy to
respond
sir please just please try to stick to
the question that i'm asking you you've
had you've had your chance to go well
beyond the question being asked but if
you could just please stick to the
question i'm asking you would go a lot
faster
could you i don't think your microphone
was on there
it's nothing it's not really a badgering
it's not it the objection but that's
that's right so just if you could answer
the question that's asked okay thank you
thank you
let me let me start over sir you're you
you charge mr depp hundred and ten
dollars an hour for the work that you do
for him don't you that is my standard
rate for all clients and yes i do charge
that rate to mr deb and you gave a
deposition in this case you remember
that on around february 2nd 2022
yes
and
that day you charged mr depp 710 an hour
for the time that you spent giving
testimony that day didn't you
yes i did
and
you charge mr depp seven hundred and ten
dollars an hour for
anything that you do in connection with
his account don't you
yes i do
you have about six people working on mr
depp's account
correct
yes
and
whether through you or one of your
colleagues your main contact with mr
depp and his companies is his sister
christy dembrowski correct no
who was your main contact
mr deb
one of your colleagues maintains active
communication with christy dambrowski
correct
could you ask a question again counselor
one of your colleagues maintains active
communication with christy dombrowski
correct no
may approach all right yes sir
thank you
mr white i've handed you the transcript
from your deposition that you gave in
this case on february 2nd 2022. you
remember that we did it over zoom
yes i do okay and you you swore to tell
the truth in that deposition as best you
can correct yes okay can you turn to
page 116 of your deposition certainly
did you say 16 counselor 116 160.
okay i have it and now you just answered
no to my question about your colleagues
maintaining communication with christy
dombrowski but at your deposition just
two months ago on line 11 of page 116
the question is what about christy
dombrowski the answer that you gave is i
do not i haven't spoken to christy in
some time one of my colleagues probably
maintains an active basis of
communications between her and our firm
did i read that right
yes but you that that's what that was
you need to find it
right sir now part of the services that
you provide that your firm provides to
mr depp is to pay his his the bills to
his doctors correct
yes
and you make payments relating to
maintenance or damages to his properties
correct
yes
now you were contacted in early 2016
right you testified to that to do work
on behalf of mr deb
we were engaged in march of 2016 if
that's your question right right around
february 10th is that when you were
first contacted
i do not recall the date and you said
you were introduced by executives a guy
named richard smith at the bank of
california
yes mr depp owed a significant amount of
money to the bank of california at that
time correct
no
he owed money to the bank of california
correct
i do not recall that he had an active
indebtedness with the bank of california
he had other
commercial loans but not with the bank
of california
and after you were brought on you
developed an understanding that mr
depp's financial status was very
challenging correct
it was challenging but we had an ability
to resolve the problems if they were
properly addressed he had liquidity
problems right
he had substantial assets in excess of
his liabilities but he had short-term
obligations indeed to be satisfied
let me just ask that again with the time
that you were brought on he had
liquidity problems correct
can you define liquidity for me
i'm i'm asking you at the time he was
brought on he had liquidity problems
correct
i would defined the term liquidity
as where the short-term assets
are less than the short-term excuse me
are
less than short-term liabilities and if
that's how you define liquidity i would
agree
in layman's terms terms that that i can
understand because i don't i don't speak
all the the kind of business school
terms that you speak
he didn't have enough money at the time
correct he was spending more than he was
bringing in correct
yes
and you gave him advice about how he
could hopefully get out of that problem
correct
yes okay and
just to be clear uh mr white because
you've testified to to some degree of
knowledge about
um
wine that you you allege that miss heard
requested so you seem to have some some
knowledge of of mr depp's spending
miss her didn't she didn't buy any of
the dozens of properties that mr depp
owned correct
correct he owns the assets prior to
their marriage she didn't pay five
million dollars to blast hunter
thompson's ashes out of a cannon did she
not to my knowledge she didn't buy a
yacht that she couldn't afford and then
have to sell it to jk rowling did she
not to my knowledge
now let's talk about that meeting on
april 21st 2016.
you said the meeting started it's about
7 30 p.m
yes and lasted until maybe 9 30 is that
right yes and you have no idea
no personal knowledge where mr depp went
after he left that meeting do you
that is correct i did not go with him i
went home
and at that meeting mr depp was given
some catastrophic news about his
business correct
he was given news that he needed to
address a number of financial issues but
i had a strategy and plan to fully
resolve them
that news that he was given that night
was catastrophic wasn't it
no
may i approach your honor yes sir
okay
mr white let's do this again with
another
under oath series of statements you gave
testimony in the uk trial did you not
yes
and that testimony was under oath
correct yes all right and in front of
you i have your testimony from the uk
trial and you gave that testimony on
behalf of mr depp correct
i gave it honestly okay
you gave it on behalf of mr depp
correct you were one of his witnesses
called that is correct okay can you
please turn to page 865
and it's just the second page of the
document upper left before that the
questions are talking about this meeting
on april 21st 2016
and you were asked the question question
now mr depp was given some catastrophic
news about his business answer
that is correct
did i read that right
you did but remember
that was just a chance you answered my
question sir i did not define that sir
mister you'll have a chance the attorney
will get back up and redirect you okay
so if you just answer his question
that's fine and the reason i'm asking
sir is because you just gave the exact
opposite testimony here so that's that's
why we pointed that out
now you at this meeting you had a
discussion about his financial affairs
and a necessity to formulate a revised
business strategy and plan correct yes
and you talked about the following
financial information you talked about
bank obligations and tax liabilities
right yes which means money you owe to
either the government or banks correct
yes
you talked about assets that he needed
to sell correct yes
properties and things like that that he
needed to sell to generate money
correct
you talked about ways to reduce spending
correct
yes
and you talked about
how to get new engagements correct
yes how to get new gigs right
not how to get them but then i encourage
to to get them
i'm not an agent i appreciate that
curious engagement and understood you
talked about the need to
get new gigs to generate additional
money to help
uh address these financial woes that he
was experiencing correct yes
you also told him at that meeting that
um
his taxes he hadn't paid taxes in years
correct
no that's not correct that he had not
paid any taxes in years is not correct
that that
he was significantly delinquent in
federal tax obligations dating back
years correct
i don't know how you're defining years
there were delinquent liabilities i
addressed them
and formulated a plan
and you talked about the significant
delinquent tax liabilities that would
run into the millions of dollars for
taxes unpaid correct
that is correct
and so after receiving these this
catastrophic news as we discussed you
have no idea where mr depp went when he
walked out of the doors of his office
correct
i do not know where he went can you pull
up plaintiff's exhibit 936 please
and mr white i'm not gonna
this is a long a long document um
that we can we can scroll through but
what i'll i'll
represent to you and and
michelle can sort of scroll down is that
these these appear to be
mr depp's tax returns for mr depp and
his companies from 2009 to 2019. do you
see that
yes
and
these are our returns as part of your
role as his cpa
firm now his business manager firm now
you your firm prepares these tax returns
correct yes and you maintain these tax
returns in the ordinary course of your
business correct that is correct
your honor i know there's going to be
plenty of redaction to do but i just
would like to move these into evidence i
don't plan to publish them or anything
at this point
you want to approach
all right so 936 will come into evidence
but i'll wait for redactions and they
will not be published okay
thank you your honor
now mr white you
you understood that
mr depp
showed up hours late for work on pirates
five correct
that is not correct
are you familiar with tracy jacobs
yes that's mr mr depp's uh former agent
correct
yes and at the time that she was serving
as his agent part of her job
responsibilities to the best of your
understanding was to communicate with
you about mr depp's financial affairs
correct
to the extent she had knowledge
right yes she would communicate and and
you and she did communicate about mr
depp correct
during the period of engagement yes we
did communicate
can you pull up defendants exhibit 874
please michelle
mr white do you
do you see here this text exchange
between you and tracy jacobs
yes and your texts are in in white and
miss jacobs are in blue correct
yes
michelle could you please scroll to um
the document that that
is bait stamped
19246
it's about the fifth or sixth one down
please
mr white do you see here the third text
down from tracy jacobs to you
saying thanks i got a call from disney
last week saying he showed up objection
your honor here
all right
it's it's not hearsay it's party
opponent she's his agent we've i'm happy
to approach if you'd like to discuss
mr white um we just saw the text that i
started reading do you remember that
text yes okay we're gonna just gonna
show you
uh and move for admission of that that
page of the document with that text so i
just wanted since you won't see anything
else i just wanted you to orient
yourself that that is the text that we
were just reading okay
fine
you're right
that page or that time you're going to
redact it just that one text thank you
your honor i would move for admission of
this document as i guess we could call
it
defendants874a okay 874a
with the redactions all right thank you
mr white um you you just testified uh a
few minutes ago that you you didn't have
any understanding of mr depp showing up
late for work on pirates five but in
fact you received this text from tracy
jacobs that says thanks
i got a call from disney last week
saying he showed up five hours late for
adr work in london for pirates five i
really need to speak to him before he
starts work on his net next project in
la did i read that right
permission to publish this your honor oh
yes i'm sorry thank you
do you want me to do you want me to
respond
i i just wanted to ask you if i if i
read that right that you received this
text message saying in part i got a call
from disney last week saying he showed
up five hours late for adr work in
london for pirates five i really need to
speak to him before he starts work on
this next project in la did i read that
right
i believe you blend it right thank you
now
at some point you became familiar
you can go ahead and take that down
thank you at some point you became
familiar as you've testified with what
amber planned to do with money that she
got from mr depp in the divorce correct
it was the understanding from the
beginning the money would be contributed
to charities the two charities the
children's hospital
children's hospital of la
and the aclu correct
that is correct and as we discussed you
wrote checks to those two organizations
that were part of
mr depp's divorce payment but they were
just sent directly to those
organizations correct yes can you please
pull up
defendants exhibit
1639
actually let's do
let's do defendants exhibit um
yeah we'll do 1639.
thanks
mr white this is a letter from you to
the aclu foundation dated august 24th
2016. correct
yes
and um
as as
part of your your work for your 100
or so high profile high net worth
clients you've helped clients set up
pledged contributions to charities
before correct yes
and sometimes those payments are made
over a period of time correct
yes charitable donations aren't always
paid at once correct
that is correct and when you make
payments on behalf of your clients to
charities um is it customary for you to
send a cover letter like this
in some instances yes and some instances
no okay but in all instances
that there is a signed agreement and an
understanding of when the yeah so that
wasn't my question my question was just
is it customary for you to send a letter
like this um and i think you've answered
that and so when you send letters like
this on behalf of your clients do you do
you prepare such letters in the ordinary
course of your business
in some instances yes and when you in
the instances in which you prepare those
letters do you then maintain those
letters in the ordinary course of your
business yes your honor i'd move for
admission of defendants exhibit one six
three nine all right objection
all right
1639 in evidence and you can
publish it to the jury thank you
and michelle if you could please just
scroll through mr white i just want you
to see there's the the letter here
um we'll come back to the letter and
then there's there's the check
that you're making out to the aclu
then there's i guess the envelope or
something right
correct okay you can go back to the
letter please
so in this in this
uh
in this cover letter
you
tell the aclu that you're closing a
check for a hundred thousand dollars
and that the donation is being made in
accordance with ms heard's pledged gift
of three and a half million to the aclu
foundation correct
and you also write that the check
represents uh
just go ahead the the check represents
uh the first
of multiple scheduled installments
correct
it was my understanding
you've asked me a question i'm trying to
reduce no i was actually just asking if
that's what you wrote
would you ask the question against face
yeah you write this check represents the
first of multiple scheduled installments
to honor the full amount of miss heard's
three and a half million dollar pledge
gift it was my understanding she was
going to contribute the money and that's
okay
i just asked if that's what you wrote
let's i think you've answered that can
we please pull up exhibit 1596.
your honor before we go to the next
exhibit can i raise an issue okay sure
thanks
mr white is this a letter
similar to what we just looked at for
the aclu
a letter um
that you wrote
that accompanied the check that you sent
to the children's hospital of los
angeles foundation yes
and
this uh letter and the whatever payment
or sorry this letter is one that you
would have prepared in the ordinary
course of business correct yes and you
would have maintained this letter in the
ordinary course of business correct yes
you're on our move for the admission of
exhibit one five nine six all right one
five nine six in evidence you can
publish it to the jury
and mr white this letter also
says at the bottom that it represents
the check that accompanies this letter
represents the first of multiple
scheduled installments to honor the full
amount of misheard's 3.5 million dollar
pledged gift correct
when i composed the letter that was my
understanding that she was going to give
three possibilities
you're really not answering my question
my question was simply i i understand
that you you wanna
you you wanna speak your own narrative
here but my question was simply that
this letter says that this check
represents the first of multiple
scheduled installments to honor the full
amount of misheard's three and a half
million dollar pledge gift correct
we can both read the letter and answers
yes thank you sir now you hosted a
dinner with mr depp um
and adam waldman in in 2016 correct
i do recall that and that was the first
time that uh
mr death had been introduced to mr
waldman correct
i do not know that be fashion now
you you are not an expert on california
divorce law right correct
and you're not an expert on the division
of marital property in california
correct
i'm not an expert but i've been actively
involved in numerous cases involving the
disillusionment of marriage
and the related proceeds are distributed
to each respected party
now you can't
give any sort of legal opinion
or testimony as to whether or not miss
heard would have been entitled to more
in the divorce settlement with mr depp
than she received correct
i'm not an attorney at law okay i don't
have your legal opinions
so
you've never met amber heard correct
that is correct the first time you've
ever seen her in person is here in this
courtroom this afternoon correct that's
my recollection and you have no personal
knowledge of whether mr depp engaged in
domestic abuse against my client
correct
i've never witnessed him
involved in any abuse and obviously i
have never met her i could not respond
to that inquiry so the answer to my
question is that it's correct that you
have no personal knowledge of whether mr
deaf engaged in domestic abuse against
amber hurt
that is correct i have no knowledge
nothing further all right redirect
mr denison
can we pull up
defendants 1596
sir could you read the last line of
your letter
this check represents the first of
multiple scheduled installments to honor
the full amount of ms heard's 3.5
million dollar pledged gift
what was the schedule for those payments
they were scheduled i i don't know the
schedule because i don't have a copy of
any pledge that she made
if that's your question
okay thank you very much
one more question
has mr depp paid all his taxes
yes he has he's fully current with all
of this federal
uh foreign and state tax obligations
thank you
all right no further questions mr all
right is this witness subject to recall
no
no
all right mr white you're free to go
thank you sir just be very careful
stepping down there okay thank you honor
thank you have a good day
all right your next witness is remote
witness correct
all right
let me just
give him donald
wait a moment
your honor may we just ask what witness
they plan to follow i i see a mr
connolly in the lobby so i'm assuming
that must be
that must be the one
okay good
good i'm glad we got that one all right
so
do
all right mr conley can you hear me
hello
yes yes sir
yep hi yeah can you turn your camera on
sir
okay there we go there we go
all right sir if you could raise your
right hand
do you swear from them tell the truth on
a penalty of law
i do all right
all right and uh good afternoon mr
connolly
good afternoon
and would you please state your full
name for the record
welcome
and mr connolly uh where are you
testifying from at the moment
uh from home uh essex uk
and and where do you live
i live in essex uk
mr connolly what is your occupation
uh at present um course protection
operative
i've had a couple of professions i'm a
bricklayer to trade i was in the
corrections facility
pentonville hms prison
but right now yeah i'm a
protection
officer
okay and and can you tell us a little
bit uh just generally
what that means
that means uh
looking after
the personal well-being
physical well-being
of any client good detail to
and how long have you been in the
personal security business
25 years
over the course of those 25 years have
you had any other kinds of jobs
yeah as i said i was a corrections
officer for a majesty prison
are you familiar with the plaintiff in
this case johnny depp
i am yes
and how do you know mr depp
yeah i know mr death uh
maybe about
23 years ago 24 years ago i worked for a
company called music and arts the guy
who won that company was jerry judge
jerry
started working with johnny
way back in the early days
and i was detailed looking after uh
johnny's ex
vanessa parity
and
jack and lily rose johnny's kids
and my my job is just to make sure
they were safe when johnny was at work
so that job
after about a year and a half two years
johnny uh asked me to go over him
directly
and we'll find someone else to do the
that and that's how i came across johnny
i said that's why that's how i
personally met johnny depp
can you ballpark for us about what year
that was
oh two thousand and
okay and can you generally just tell us
a little bit about what you do uh for mr
depp
as his security guard
um i will escort johnny to everyday uh
public
places
make sure he's okay make sure uh
you know he's not in any danger
first of all do the reiki you know you
go along first there's usually a two-man
team it's a two-man detail
you go along do your recce make sure all
the ins and outs are
sorted
no compromises any risks involved risk
assessment
we do the job
i'll look after them basically i look
after johnny whenever we're in public
domain
whenever we're going to be in a public
domain
i will look after johnny
okay and uh and how about the defendant
in this case amber heard are you are you
familiar with miss hurd
i am familiar with sergio i am
i first met miss heard in probably two
000 and
i don't recall exactly the actual date
probably about 2010
maybe around there uh she came into the
uk
to do a promotional job for a movie
called drive angry
my boss studied jerry judge asked me to
take the detail
uh
went and met amber
started the job amber was with our ex
tosh tasha
and uh
i looked after amber for a week
pleasant week it was fine great
uh does anything
sorry yeah
after that week
i never seen amber again until we did
the rum diaries
the premier uh after show we were on
diary
okay uh so
let's move to the to the rum diary then
uh when did you see miss heard um well
how did you see miss hurd in connection
with
uh the rum diary
um we were
we've done the rum diary premiere we
went to the after show party uh you know
i'm busy working doing my job myself and
jerry judge
uh i've seen amber across the floor
amber seeing me
just basically come across the floor set
hello how are you doing you know you use
your chit chat you check chatty for a
minute or two
uh johnny asked me how i actually knew
amber
explained uh that's the last spoke
chamber that night i was too busy
doing my job you know
did you know at the time and uh well
let's back up for a second where was
that premiere
um do you know what i don't recall
i think it was
i think it was an early
okay i don't like to recall
okay
did you know at the time of that uh
premiere in
probably la but possibly somewhere else
um did you know at the time that mr depp
and miss heard were seeing each other
romantically
no i didn't i actually didn't i mean i i
surmised that
there was a spark there you know it
wasn't so
maybe
maybe a
few days later a few nights later
we
well i've done a party somewhere or a
promotional thing
and uh
amber and johnny were basically you know
sparking sparking out there
they were getting together then i i
assumed that you know there was a
romance happening there budding there
you know
okay
over the course of
mr depp and mr heard's relationship with
each other
about how often would you say you saw
them together
well in the beginning actually not a lot
you know not a lot
maybe once a week yeah
twice a week
but then it started uh
well it started maturing into something
in our relationship
so
more often
more often the time went on you know
and just as time went on did you have an
opportunity to observe uh how mr depp
and mister interacted with each other
uh at the beginning um oh you know
lovey-dovey everything was great the
honeymoon period was on and it was uh
yeah it was good i mean it was great
great to see johnny happy again amber
was you know
lovely charming
as she usually is you know
good as gold
and then things you know things started
to change amber started to change amber
started
getting a bit i would say a bit more
uh feisty
demanding you know
i could see that amber wanted to wear
the pants in this relationship that was
pretty obvious
and
what in particular made you think that
that you observed personally
um just just the way uh
you know if something wasn't quite right
or
uh
amber could uh amber could get a bit
frosty at the drop of a hat
so as time went on you know i could see
them
i could see them change i could see i
could see amber change i could see
johnny getting quieter
uh we get into the car and nobody was
speaking
and you know it's just things started
changing changing amber started getting
a bit more
grumpy
how did she uh how did she get along
with you
absolutely fine i i uh
amber was
fine with me
amber was never anything but
professional polite
with me you know she was uh no amber was
finally me
did you ever uh
see or hear
any arguments between mr depp and miss
hurt
[Music]
when you say see
i heard i mean i could hear at times and
certain accommodations would be staying
out
i could hear
amber
yeah screaming you know
i could hear shouting and bawling and
yeah i could hear it going on yeah
but i mean i wasn't there every sit
every single night
when we were working in the uk
those nights maybe i'd get home
because jerry would be there but yeah
yeah i did hear yeah definitely for a
fact i would i could hear sometimes the
shouting and bowling you know it's most
mostly i could hear amber screaming you
know
about how
i recognized this was years ago but can
you can you estimate for us how
regularly that happened
uh
i can't say regularly i can't say it was
like every day
but you know it get more regular got
more more often than not
did you ever uh
did you ever witness any physical
violence
between the two of them no
no never i'd never seen any physical
violence
it's not a thing
it's not a thing people would do in
front of security it's not a thing that
would happen in front of myself or gary
judge or sean better some it just
wouldn't happen
it wouldn't happen
no i never seen any physics physical
security i've never seen any hands-on no
okay what do you mean you never saw any
hands-on
well i never seen any slapping or
grabbing or punching or hitting
i've never seen any of that physically i
said well
well i'll tell you what there was like
an instance maybe
two entities that come in my mind one
incident was on a private plane
i can't recall was a domestic flight or
an international flight
i'm sitting
johnny amber or johnny whoever he's
flying with will sit up at the four
tables the four table
up aft
and
myself
and my colleagues will sit down
the
furred end of the plane so i i usually
look up the fuselage that way
with my back to the nose
amber had her back to me johnny's
sitting across the table
and there was a bickering going on i
can't hear because you know you talk
about jet craft i can't actually hear
and it's more animated than verbal
and
uh
i see her i see her later a plastic
lighter
bounce off his chest boom bounce you
know bounce off his chest
so right away i think well this this is
going to escalate
see they're going to go one way or the
other
i don't think it came to much
uh
i remember johnny just us you know
smirking and looking away just to say
you know well what was that it
kind of kind of attitude you know
and johnny johnny touch his heart puts
his head against the window and
whoa
i'm out you know
another time i was at the loft apartment
i was in the
security room in the loft apartments
with a security guard called
do you know what i can't recall if it
was sean bay i've got a guy called
donovan
anyway i got the text i would donate to
pick him up to go to
the west hollywood
accommodation
and uh i've got the text uh objection to
the to the extent he's going to talk
about what the text is that's hearsay
uh
you you can just tell us what you
observed without looking at that without
recounting the contents of the text okay
okay i'm instructed to go and get johnny
and because we're leaving saying
objection he just he just said what he
was instructed to do all right i'll just
i'll stay in the objection if you can
what did you do after you received the
text
i go to the
loft apartment
uh the doors are just slightly just like
just a we call a crack in the door
push the door open and i go and
shout there's a bit of shouting going on
i can't really i can't hear i mean i'm
in the wrong area of the apartment
but as i turn as i turn to the left into
the mud of the lounge area
there's a soda can
like i i don't know i don't know if it's
a coca-cola or a sprite or i don't know
what it was
but it's launched from the mezzanine
and johnny's uh
had this huge tv
the biggest tv i've ever seen
but this and it's on this mechanical arm
which is
an actual piece of artwork that johnny
had got commissioned
and anyway this this big mechanical arm
holds this tv
so this kind of pop you're going to call
it pop
smash is that
but by force let me add because it means
a bang boom
and now i i can hear is it spraying all
over the place
johnny has already got his jacket on and
a bag over his shoulder
that's why he's called me in because
we're leaving
i just pick up the other bags two bags
pick up the two bags put my hand through
johnny's arm i say they thought we're
leaving
we walk out the door we walk out the
door and we go
halfway to s
to the
west hollywood
johnny's already calm down you know he's
like
objection objection to that he's talking
about what mr depp is saying all right
i'll sustain objection gonna continue uh
if you if you have uh
i i think we can move on okay all right
next question
uh just just to clarify um mr connolly
when uh
when the soda can was launched from the
mezzanine
where was mr depp in relation to where
the soda can land
probably 10 feet 10 that uh probably 10
feet back from that 10 feet back from
that
okay and just to make sure we're on the
same page when you refer to the loft
departments uh what are you referring to
the downtown early eastern building
okay
um
what was your
did you form any understanding as to
where um
as to who had thrown the soda can
um objection speculation okay hold on
sir speculation foundation i'm just
asking if if he formed an understanding
and he can state the basis for that if
he if he did if you want to lay a
foundation did you did you uh to your
knowledge was miss heard present in the
apartment at the time objection leading
yes
i never seen her physically but i could
hear a voice
and and where did her could you tell
where her voice was coming from
upstairs or just upstairs
okay she wasn't on the lower the lower
apartment with us so i can only imagine
she was upstairs
other than the uh other than the
cigarette lighter and the soda can
anything else similar to that that you
observed
no no i can't say no no
did you ever observe any physical
injuries on this hurt
never no
how about on mr down
yeah
yeah
yes
yeah it started off with maybe a a
scratch once in a while or you know
a swelling but it get good more it got
more yeah i'm not talking he was marked
every every week or every two weeks but
yeah he he he sustained mark there
definitely he was getting married
and can you describe for us
what you can remember
yeah um
objection you're on a queen
all right hold on mr conley for a minute
uh so mr connolly you can you can
continue uh responding i think the
question was just can you generally
describe for us what you remember about
the the marks you saw on mr depp
yes
uh
as i was saying
in the prison service you're taught to
uh
pick up log in your mind mental mental
logging in your mind
marks bruises bully patterns stuff
what i noticed right away
was most of these marks and most of
these things
through my training
that's happening in the left-hand side
of his face
and it would be scratches on his neck
maybe a a fat lip in the corner
maybe a bruising on on the eye socket
um
dull impacts you know except for
obviously the scratches maybe on his
belly's left ear sometimes it'd be two
two marks two lines two charms
one
yeah you know
yeah
it was getting it was getting more
regular i might as i say not every week
but it was definitely happening yeah
can we see
plaintiff's exhibit 162 please
and mr connolly uh are you able to see
the picture on i i assume you can see it
on your screen
yeah just gonna thank you please
yeah hi yeah
and do you uh
yeah i know that picture i took that
picture you took pictures
yeah i took the picture
can you just quickly tell us what what
this picture is
this picture is a
misheard and johnny's
honeymoon
on the origin express
on the east line
from
bangkok to
singapore
you travel through malaysia stop the
kuala lumpur and a few other places in
the way down and that is in the
the dining coach i think yeah dining
coach that's where that is the guy on
the left there with a silver band around
his he's the waiter he's the way to
the detail to look after us
the guy in the bow tie
he's the guest relations manager mr mr
just hold on one second um before we
continue describing the document i'd
move for the admission of plaintiff's
trial exhibit 162 and that it be
published to the jury any objection
i'd like to approach it okay
you can publish
all right and mr connolly i apologize
for cutting you off but could you just
continue to describe for us uh what
we're looking at in this picture
yeah as i said the guy in the bow tie
he's the guest relations manager he was
detailed to
you know
fixes up anything we needed
uh you know to excursions and
transports and stuff
then it's misheard
the guy that's the chef he looked after
this he was he cooked for his great chef
by the way
yeah he looked after us and that's
johnny and i also noticed if you look at
that picture
like i said
on the left hand side under his eye
there's a swelling
and you see a swelling just on the left
hand side of his nose and under his left
eye
and what do you interpret that swelling
to be
do
what do i interpret as
that's uh
either he's walked into a door
or a door's walked into him
okay
can you tell us anything and we can take
this down i think
thank you
uh mr connolly can you tell us uh well
first of all what uh
do you recall what year mr depp and and
miss heard went on their honeymoon uh in
the picture we were just looking at
um
that would
that i don't know the two thousand and
2017
okay and were you uh well you testified
that you took the picture so you were
there i assume
absolutely yes
um
what can you tell us about that trip
generally and particularly focused on
how mr depp and ms heard were
interacting with each other
um started off good started off good uh
johnny's cabin was maybe
15 meters down the corridor from maine
there was no cabins in between
that was uh like store rooms like you
know blankets and cutlery and stuff
uh so
the cabin was quite
not a big massive distance but you know
it wasn't like
the this trip started flying
absolutely fine
i think it was five six days five days
maybe
two days three days into the trip uh
i can see johnny going down i can see
him coming down you know
uh
he's just he's just not enjoying this
he's not enjoying us
but you know i can't it's not my
business to to step in than that i just
do my job but i can see he's not
enjoying this
like he's just not he's not happy
he's not happy
did you ever observe any arguments
between mr deputy in this time frame
just not arguments but uh
some frostiness misheard uh
sort of demanded that you know we have
our own
dining cart if you like
so me doing my job i inquire
to the the guest relations guy there
that you've seen in the photograph
and he quite really tells me that you
know there's other objections objections
objection to hearsay all right i think
we can move on okay i'll stay in the
action next question
all right so mr uh
mr connolly um
well taking a step back for a minute and
changing topics slightly
have you ever seen mr depp use any drugs
i don't think
i'll allow it go ahead
yes i've seen him
smoke marijuana
i had my suspicions i have my suspicions
that when he goes off to the bathroom he
he
he probably does about cocaine
i've never seen him do it as mr depp
would never do
a line or anything like cocaine in front
of me or jerry judge or sean better
anybody mr
johnny depp would never compromise my my
license my position
and embarrass me like that it wouldn't
happen so to answer to your question
i've seen him smoke weed gift
he noticed any particular
what changes if any have you noticed in
his behavior when he's under the
influence of marijuana
um
to be honest
a bit more
a bit more
relaxed no sort of tight but i mean he's
he's not he's not
he's not always head
he's perfectly functioning i mean
you can talk about anything any
conversation you want to talk about
he's neither up nor down with that you
know he really isn't
he's a very high tolerance for any
substance johnny you know i would say so
you know
i think jack sparrow's more drunk than
johnny depp
so okay so that's that's uh marijuana
what about alcohol same question
um
alex well he used to like a wine
and the last the last um i would say the
last
couple years that's dropped drastically
as well
let's say
know in my last year with johnny it's
quite actually rare now he's not rare
but
he's not he's not a big person now he's
not abusing though you know he's not
and he was never he was never out of his
head and when he was never you know
i think i've seen drunk in the 25 20 or
years of him with johnny i think i've
seen him drunk twice
and but when i say drunk i mean drunk
other than that
there's not a lot of difference in
johnny's demeanor of behavior
well you're drinking alcohol or smoking
weed you know
okay
and and finally uh
same ques same question for the time
periods when you
formed the suspicion that he was under
the influence of cocaine
sorry what was that sorry could you ask
me that again what changes in his
behavior if any
did you observe on those occasions when
you suspected but didn't know for sure
that he was under the influence of
cocaine
well again
due to the training i had in uh you know
the
hmp prison service
it just seemed a bit uh
a bit more
i don't know
happier up
not so down you know
but i wouldn't say he's not leaping
around kicking his heels or anything
he you know you pick his guitar up and
he and then he gets he gets right into
his guitar and
there's no major changes really you know
he just
he's fine you know
okay now you mentioned you traveled with
uh mr depp and miss heard on their
honeymoon um
in in on the orient express um
where else have you traveled with them
all over the world uh japan china
uh germany i've been all over the states
uh
went to an interest not please say
hicksville
that's an interesting story
uh
yeah all over the world uh
australia
went to australia
how far away is that
and and uh let's let's take that one at
a time hicksville you said
yeah hexbill yeah um
it's uh funky
i remember because i remember hicksville
because it was a funky it's a real funky
place you know
uh
with the amber and
johnny they've decided they're going to
go to hicksville
for uh you know a day
a day in the night i think it was
so we are off the chart the amber would
hunt our friends all head off and uh
well amber traveled with johnny but our
friends all head off
uh i followed johnny wanted to drive his
own uh
a beautiful big
customized plymouth i think it's a 58 or
50 i don't know not experts but you had
to customize do you want to drive this
this this car
myself and uh his assistant at the time
nathan holmes we
use another johnny's cars and we follow
behind
we we get to joshua tree mexico
they're stunning as you can imagine
but it's a it's it's done in a a very
funky theme
all the caravans are different themes
you know like it means there's an old
real wicked boots
with the old foot you know the old
the
you know fairground fortune teller head
that comes around and stuff
johnny's the numbers caravan were
maybe about 15 meters from mine
maybe 20 meters and it was that was done
in like the 1950s styles you know like
kitschy 1950s
kind of thing and the rest of the
caravans were all you know zombies
coming out the ground and
scavenues
anyway we go there there's a lot of
booze all the booze comes up
uh party starts well sitting around in
the sun messing around party starts
so there's loads of booze and uh
weed
and i think there's mushrooms yeah
some psychedelic mushrooms
that's that's going around
but the night gets a bit ruined as
as i'm watching exactly what's all
happening everybody's happy you know
johnny amber everybody's happy
as well as i'm watching what's happening
i can see
johnny amber getting a bit animated
and there were probably about maybe 25
feet from me
so i
approach
and
i've been working with johnny that long
i don't have to really say anything i
only have to look at his face
and johnny can talk to me through his
face he didn't need to work
so i know what's happening so
like and i've seen the little boys
guys let's keep this private let's you
know let's start walking towards the
caravan let's you know take this away
from here
as i'm walking ahead you know just you
know going ahead
i can hear
you know bickering behind me
johnny's kind of
talking you know low tone you know you
know keep keeping a bit quiet but
amber's getting a bit more but a bit
more loud a bit more
narky
you know so anyway i get them to the
caravan i put them inside
and i go to my caravan
that's it i
don't hear anything don't see anything
until the next morning
we sit around the pool
a couple of hours and uh we head back to
early
what prompted you
do you have a lot of direct still left
in this matter
uh
[Music]
not terribly much more maybe ten
take your afternoon break then please
let's go ahead and take your 15-minute
afternoon break and then we'll come back
and continue with the testimony okay
don't do any outside research and don't
talk to anybody
all right mr conley i'm going to put you
in the lobby for our break okay i'm
going to come back and put you back in
about 4 20 our time okay in about 17
minutes about 17 minutes okay sir
all right just don't discuss your test
all right just don't discuss your
testimony with anybody until then okay
okay all right thank you
all right
thank you
all right are we ready for the jury
okay
all right
all right mr connie can you hear me okay
i can't yes
can you just count to count to five for
me please
one two three four five perfect thank
you all right
next question
all right mr connolly um we were talking
about hicksville there and you made a
comment that um
you had suggested to mr depp and miss
heard that they
they keep it private or something along
those lines
uh good job
mike my question is just what prompted
you to make that suggestion
well it was getting kind of uh animated
you know it's in
animated and you know no one wants to
see the
[Music]
earth of dirty laundry in public
uh were they both animated
more so
amber
johnny yes but more so amber
okay
do you remember anything in particular
that miss heard was saying at the
time don't recall no
as i say i it wasn't really coherent it
was more of the animation that you know
the
the head movements and the stem looks
and stuff that made prompting me to do
what i have to do you know
okay
uh shifting gears a little bit um
you listed out various places that you
traveled with with mr deb and miss heard
and i think you listed japan germany
hicksville and australia do i have that
right
correct yes
when were you in australia
i'll be
15 2015
pirates
5. and uh
what were you doing in australia
uh
my job uh
i
in that case and i
flew out first i used to fly at first to
do the advance
uh the advance includes
the checking accommodation
not so much accommodation because uh
nathan holmes
uh ben king
and the chef called russell they had
already been been at the home excuse me
been at the home
and got that sorted out
my main concern was locations
transport uh
local security
drivers you know
making sure all that's in line before
johnny gets there
jerry judge would have traveled with
johnny in australia
on arrival uh i would have picked him up
at the airport as we do
take him to the the house or whatever
accommodation was staying in
and uh i would have peeled off for the
left that
went back to my apartment
johnny would have been
maybe it could be up to a week for
you know makeup costume before any
shooting stuff
and which time it gives me a time to run
around some locations
the studio check out the studio the
locations
as well as be around for if johnny wants
to go for dinner at night anywhere i
would check out these places as well
mr connolly i'm sorry i i just had a
little trouble hearing you there could i
might be the might be the connection but
could you speak maybe just a little bit
slower i'm sorry
okay
um as i say my job when in australia is
just to secure all the advance
so i would check out make sure the local
drivers are there all the cars are in
order the accommodations in order
the locations
for shooting are all safe
liaison with production
what's expected of them
i would pick him up at the airport when
he arrives take him to their
accommodation
peel off go and check out a few
restaurants in case you want to go
and if nothing's happening
standing
for that evening
does anything stand out to you about
your time in australia in 2015
yeah johnny lost a finger
um
yeah
yeah one afternoon i was uh instructed
to go to johnny's accommodation
objection and can we just
okay all right
hold on it's been a missionary
all right mr mr connolly um please
continue but but as you as you go please
avoid um
discussing the substance of any
communications that you had with mr depp
uh or or his security and just focus on
what you observed
okay
i arrived
at johnny's accommodation
as my driver andrew
i noticed that there's an suv
one of the security the the rst resident
security team
one of their vehicles is sitting outside
the door no driver
so
i just assumed
just well something up was a security
car there but no driver
as i approached the door i hear a muffle
like a muffled
shouting and screaming and
you know
quite muffled though because the
entrance to this house there's a massive
oak door i mean it's huge
and it's got to be about 25 mil thick
so i often
and it's chaos it's uh
screaming and shouting but
oh all i can see with my eyes is johnny
he's wearing a
jacket
a hat
and a bag with his notebooks
i always know that bag because it's a
great canvas bag
and he's
sort of you know nuts in one hand
so i'm saying well hey what's going on
button it's screaming and shouting
it's madness
amber's amber's irate i mean
tenacious it's crazy stuff
johnny's uh you know shouting back
so i've said johnny let's go let's go
you know
that's my job to remove them from a
situation
let's go
i do a couple of steps for them johnny
give me five minutes now five minutes
well he's a boss you know
there's nobody there's no bullets flying
so
okay give him two minutes how about i
see let's go let's go eventually i get
him out i managed to get him outside the
door
we go downstairs
but amber appears from somewhere no i
don't know if i was upstairs or in the
room to the left or
wherever
but she appears and she's screaming
you know screaming
but eating them she's basically berating
them
like yeah [ __ ] off she's saying johnny
yeah that's what you [ __ ] off that's
what you do all the time that's all you
ever do is [ __ ] off you [ __ ] off with
your guys you're [ __ ] covered that's
what you [ __ ] do
you [ __ ] coward yeah [ __ ] off with
your guys your big man all that all that
[ __ ] that goes with it
get some downstairs
uh palestine members on the threshold of
the the
the
accommodation
she's uh screaming you know [ __ ] off
your [ __ ] camera that you kind of
works or not
and uh i get them in the car and i want
to sit in the same i usually sit in the
front seat shotgun but i want to sit in
the same seat at the back
so i can have a look at what's going on
here and have a chat and have a talk
but when i get around the car
the driver has not locked the door
so he's out the door again and he's
making his way back up the stairs i get
back around again
by the time i get to the top of two two
concrete stairs to the front door
he's just crossing the threshold
and
the screaming start
against with me amber is screaming
again johnny let's go let's go
and this time it's a wee bit more force
and i managed to actually basically pull
him out of the place
get him into the car doors are locked
this time
into the car when we take off
i got them back to my apartment using uh
you know a secret way through the
underground car park and
serviceless
i get them up to my apartment
get them in my apartment while she
started washing his hand basically three
hours in his hand washing the first aid
it's a mess his hand his finger's just a
mess it's like one of them cartoon
exploding cigars i was always thinking
in my mind that one of them
one of them
blow up you know the cartoons boom
and then and it's soft laughing around
and i could see bone there's bone there
so it's smashed a bit and he's you know
he's wincing as i'm trying to wash his
hand
uh anyway i set him down and i phoned
debbie and debbie and us who's living in
the same apartment both with me so
that's my first thing phone debbie
fun debbie about 20 minutes later
if that i'd wrote the call
uh maybe 25 maybe half an hour
but she turns up with the doctor kipper
so um
dr kipper does his thing nurse debbie
dresses all the kipper the same right
this there's no there's perhaps go to
the hospital with us there's no there's
no other way we have to go to the
hospital this has to be seriously looked
at
we get to the hospital and that's when
he's uh well he that's when he's keeping
started you know
okay
um
when you
when you were in the presence of of mr
depp and miss heard in the house in
australia
um
how far away were you from this herd
um
when i first entered the house miss head
wasn't visible to me
only johnny it's only when we started to
leave
this haird appeared
and she's probably
well you're talking
two feet three feet
did you observe any injuries on this
hurt
no injuries no no
[Music]
i'm sorry what was your answer
other than the injury to his finger did
you observe any injuries on mr on mr deb
no
no
no
well
i say no
you know there was there was a mark in
his face and i i didn't know what that
was so i never really put it down too
much
but uh in the hospital i took a
photograph
and when i look when i look at that
photograph
i can see two injuries
when we're sitting in the car i'm
hold on mr khan
objection to the extent he's going to be
talking about what the mark is on his
since he didn't see what happened and
he's not a doctor we can't describe what
sorry
uh that's fine you're on a weekend okay
yeah all right next question
um
i think you've generally described for
us uh
the kinds of things ms heard was saying
how would you describe her overall
demeanor when when she and mr depp were
in the in in each other's presence in
the house in australia
good days and bad days
i i'm sorry i mean on that particular
day
on that particular day i had never seen
him in the house that particularly the
only the time i seen
misheard and johnny in that house is
when i arrived there to extract them
and how did miss heard seem to you when
you saw her uh on that day when you
arrived to extract him
crazy crazy
crazy
fierce you know fierce
okay
what was the uh what was the last thing
miss heard said as you were taking mr
death out of the house to to go to your
apartment and then the hospital
yeah
the last one what i recall hearing is as
i'm getting johnny out is yeah just [ __ ]
off you guys you're [ __ ] covered like
you always do
all right i have no further questions
all right cross-examination
um
mr connolly
you still work for mr depp
i do yeah okay and you've worked for him
now for about 18 years
no
well two years ago you said you worked
for him for 16 years so two more years
would be 18. no i i worked with him i
didn't work for him i worked for a guy
called jerry judge and music and arts
johnny depp never paid me
johnny depp started paying me two years
ago okay so now you're being so you were
working jerry judge was your jerry judge
was your boss until he passed away is
that right
okay and now and now you get paid
directly by mr deb correct
right
you paid a salary by mr deb
no
okay
and you mr depths also provided you
gifts correct
gifts gifts
money gift yes
yes guess johnny gave me guest stuff
gave johnny good get and you've had
she's given you gifts over eighty five
hundred dollars correct
eighty five hundred dollars yeah
you give me a lot more than that okay
and you're loyal to mr depp right
i'm yes of course i'm loyal to myself
i'll be loyal to you if i was working
for you okay
um
now going to australia you said you went
to australia in 2015 with mr depp
correct
or you went before mr depp but you you
were there to work for mr death correct
all right and and jerry judge was also
there
not when i wrote no but he eventually
was jerry judge was eventually in
australia correct
right and nathan holmes was also in
australia as well right
right
and mr depp came to australia in
february of 2015. correct
correct and when
when
mr depp first came to australia amber
was not with mr depp right
i don't recall i don't recall if amber
arrived with johnny or
a amber alive later
you don't know one way or the other
no
and mr deputy stayed in a house in
australia correct
right and you and the security team were
about 40 minutes away from the house mr
depp was running correct
25 30.
twenty
thirty forty yeah you could yeah you're
correct if it's a traffic day you have
40 minutes or more
and alcohol was in the house in
australia correct
and mr depp consumed alcohol before
amber arrived in australia isn't that
right
yeah he would have done yes okay and
you know if mr depp consumed illegal
drugs before amber arrived in australia
and object to speculation
i wouldn't know
good
and
do you know if mr depp spent any time
with marilyn manson in australia before
amber arrived
don't recall i don't recall i don't
recall marlon mansion being there
so you don't so as mr def security you
don't know if if mr depp was with
marilyn manson and i i left
i left australia to smuggle two dogs
back out or steal your back too no no
i'm talking about it i'm talking about
in the beginning of march 2015
you were that you were called
you don't know one way or the other
no
were you were you seeing mr depp every
day
in early margin
nope not the beginning i don't know
duties okay
so you don't know what mr depp was doing
at that time correct
no i wasn't with them okay and you don't
know when amber arrived into uh in
australia correct
no
okay but you do know that amber stayed
with mr depp right
yes okay and you talked about a resident
security team that was at the um
australia house is that right
that's correct
and were there about four
is it
was there anyone it from the resident
security team in the house when you
arrived on uh march 8 2015.
no okay and the r and the resident
security team
is it your understanding that they were
there that they were kind of guarding
the house
they would have been in the grounds but
the substantial grounds
real substantial ground
they would have hit the ground somewhere
but they didn't but they didn't go into
the house on on march 8th correct
i don't know i never seen them in the
house okay
and so when you arrived at the house and
and went and went in was it just
mr depp and amber heard
just mr depp number her okay and before
maybe someone else here i never visibly
seen anyone else i wasn't there long
enough to chat
to anybody and when you arrived at the
house you could you could hear a ruckus
correct
yes well yes i could hear yeah yeah i
could hear definitely hear something
through the the door yeah
but you said the door was so thick you
couldn't hear the actual words that were
being said is that right
no just uh
a shouting
and then you saw then you went in the
house and saw mr depp in the foyer
correct
yes correct and mr depp was trying to
urinate in the four year wasn't he
no
mr depp had his penis out objection
sydney
i think
next question and you were trying to get
mr deb out of the house correct
correct i'll try to get mr deadpool out
of the house yet and mr depp was
refusing to leave the house was he not
not so much refused he just wanted two
minutes to seize peace you took mr
depp's arm to try to move him out but he
broke away isn't that right
yes okay
i mean so he was strong enough to break
away from your grip correct no
so
you had his arm and he broke away though
correct
no
isn't that what you just said
no i let him go you let go
but it wasn't easy it wasn't funny
so mr depp's your boss you'll do what mr
deb wants correct
no
it's not easy to get mr depp out of the
house correct
not easy okay now can we put can we play
um exhibit 380a which is already in
evidence
planos are defendants i'm sorry uh it's
defendants exhibit 380a
what what is this uh sorry what is this
and this is a recording from australia
and it's just of mr depp
i don't think that's an evidence here do
you hold on it's not in evidence are
plaintiffs exhibit 380a i don't believe
there are any recordings from australia
and evidence here i don't
i don't have 380 in evidence
it's 380a
i have jamie says it was id'd but never
admitted
it was never admitted it was
your honor the recordings from australia
have other voices on them we're only
asking for the it's only the clip of mr
dab okay
it's actually plaintiff's 380 a
minute 33 to 34.
what's the foundation for using it with
this witness he was at he was at the
house
it's an evidence that's fine
so you're playing that clip correct
correct that is on plaintiffs
[Music]
and make me feel sick
of myself
there's still a lot left in the day
did you did you hear that mr connolly
i did yes and that was the sort of
condition mr depp was in when you saw
him at the house correct
yes yes
mr depp was upset and angry when you saw
him at the house correct
absolutely yes okay
now
did you take did you take mr depp to the
hospital
along with others yes
is it your testimony that mr depp was
coherent at the hospital
yes
um can you let's
show um defendants exhibit 370 and i
just like you to look at something for a
moment
i'm not i'm not putting it i'm not
publishing i just want to
show him a document defendants exhibit
370.
your honor i'm going to object on
foundation grounds the witness has not
even copied on this document i'm i'm
going to ask him a question and ask him
if
it refreshes his recollection that's all
i was going to ask him about i can i can
use any document or refresh
you can take it down
was um mr depp's finger was filled with
dirt grime and paint when you saw it
yes
and now you say you saw no bruises or
cuts on on amber on march 8 2015 correct
correct isn't it true that your main
concern was mr depp and getting him out
of the house correct
so you weren't you weren't concentrating
on amber correct
i was close enough if there was any
marks on amber's face i would have
picked that up in two minutes as you're
trying to change this
as you're trying to pull as you're
trying to pull as you're trying to pull
mr depp out of the house you're you're
scanning amber for bruises and cuts
no scanning but i'm looking at her
as you're moving as you're moving mr
depp out of the house correct yes right
how do i know what she's going to lift
right
i'm watching her when i'm when i move a
client from a bar situation a house
situation i watch what's happening
around me but you're not i know where
the client is the client's with me
right the client was with you and you're
not scanning you didn't scan miss herd's
body for i scan everything you stand
everything on her body
not everything in her body she's wearing
long sleeves from what i recall okay
um and
at the hospital the doctor was told that
mr depp cut his finger with a knife
correct
correct yeah okay
and you understand that the damage at
the house
mr depp at mr departed house amounted to
about a hundred thousand dollars correct
objection calls for speculation
i'll allow it
next question
in hicksville other than when you first
arrived you didn't go to the trailer
that mr depp and amber were saying is
that right
only when i delivered them to it right
and then after you delivered them
together
when i delivered them to it when we
first got there right and said had to
look around yeah but after that you
never went inside the trailer after that
correct
correct so you have no idea what went on
in the trailer between mr depp and amber
isn't that right
i was told
but you have no idea you don't have any
personal knowledge as well i've never
seen it right well i never seen it and
you know you have no idea how much
damage was done to the trailer correct
personal knowledge you have an idea
you have no idea what happened to amber
in the trailer isn't that right
that's correct
and you don't and and you talked about
that there was tension between amber and
mr deputy you don't know what started
the fight correct
right
did you see mr depp grab another woman's
arm before they moved off to the truck
before
the fight started
no okay were you with mister were you
with the company when you were were you
with the group
no okay
i was i was maybe
20 feet away observing that's my job not
to get involved i don't sit with my
clients in a personal situation i've
just observed
now
you testified
that at times you saw
marks and
bruises on mr depp a fat lip i think you
said
um
you don't have dates for those times
that you saw that right
i don't recall no you're talking that's
a long time ago you know
right and you testified and you
testified in the uk in this you
testified in the uk correct
correct and you gave a witness statement
too in the uk correct
right and and you never testified to
seeing any marks bruises or injuries on
mr depp isn't that right in the uk
i wasn't asking the uk but you never
testified that you never testified to
that right
i wasn't asking okay
now
use in the private you talked about a
private plane that you saw a plastic
lighter bounce off of mr depp's chest
correct
right and you said you saw mr mr depp
smirking and said and then he said was
that it is that right
no
okay you didn't you don't know what
started the fight there correct
correct okay
and
you talked about at the easter at the eb
at the uh lofts i think you called it in
los angeles
you saw a coke can
get thrown
somewhere in the vicinity of mr depp
correct
i've seen a can
right not caught i couldn't tell you
what kind it was okay
and you don't know
what happened before you saw the coke
can get thrown correct
right okay
and
you talk you talked about this picture
of um
that you took in in southeast asia
correct
right okay
and you never mentioned in the
uk matter or in your witness statement
mr depp having scratches and bruises on
the train correct
i was never prompted i was never asked
you gave a witness statement that gave
the the
what you saw and the relationship
between amber and mr depp and you never
talked about
bruises or cuts on mr on mr depp in
southeast asia correct
no i wasn't asked that okay
um now
you said oh only johnny could make
requests for a private dining car isn't
that right
i said that
could
only johnny needed a private dining car
miss her didn't need a private dining
car correct
that would be correct oh yeah that'd
definitely be correct yeah only only
johnny depp would need a private dining
car but johnny doesn't want a private
dining car
okay
now you were not present and misheard
and misheard in mr dep's cabin on the
train right
no and if a fight occurred
and if a fight occurred in the cabin
you'd have no way of knowing about it
right
i wouldn't know and you don't know if mr
depp was
strangling this hurt do you
no i wouldn't know you don't know if mr
depp had his shirt wrapped around
amber's neck do you
objection speculation communal life
no i wouldn't know the only way i would
the only reason i would know anything in
that cabinet okay you you wouldn't know
you answered sir sir so you answered
that all right
we can move on okay
and
um if we could put up please um
plaintiff's exhibit
120
and this is at 190 and i believe 120
has been
in evidence i have 120 a 120 b and 120 c
so i think this would be 120 d if it 120
d
yeah and i would
mr connolly i'm i'm asking you questions
about the
fourth
um
one down do you see that
yeah it's not really okay i'm going to
um the document is hearsay i don't know
what the exception would be okay i'll
hold if you want to come forward
mr connolly
you agree that miss hurt's been nothing
but respectful and professional to you
correct
absolutely right
okay
thank you i have nothing further all
right redirect
uh mr mr connolly very briefly uh when
you were in miss herd's presence in the
house in australia uh on the day that mr
depp uh lost his fingertip
how far away were you from miss heard
on the exit
on the the egress
about
three feet four feet at most
can you estimate for us about how long
you were in miss herd's presence
oh you know what best way to do this is
think about it and count it out okay
seconds 20 seconds
how was the light
well it's australia the door is uh
massive
it's a wall of glass behind them the
light is absolutely fine you couldn't
get better
all right i have nothing further all
right is this
subject to recall
i
think i think so yes your honor all
right mr connolly since you're subject
to recall did not discuss your testimony
with anybody and don't watch anything
about this case okay but you're free to
log off today
all right you're free to log off today
though sir thank you have a good day
thank you
all right your next witness
mr jenkins
yeah
mr jenkins can you hear me sir
good afternoon yes i can your honor all
right perfect thank you sir all right
if you raise your right hand for me
do you swear firm to tell the truth
under penalty of law
i do all right thank you sir
good morning mr jenkins can you hear me
okay
yes i can and could you please state
your full name for the record
starling jenkins iii
and mr jenkins where do you live
los angeles california
and what is your occupation
executive chauffeur secure
and how long have you worked as an
executive chauffeur and in security
executive chauffeur for 30 years
security
for eight years
and and what occupations did you hold
prior to working as an executive
chauffeur and and in security
route sales executive
and united states marines
mr jenkins do you know the plaintiff in
this case johnny depp
yes i do and when did you first meet mr
depp
1993
how did you first meet mr dab
he used delivery service to transport
him to and from
and so in in the 30 or so years that
you've known mr depp what services have
you performed for him uh over the course
of that period
child care animal care
personal assistant duties security and
transportation
and and could you uh estimate
approximately how many hours per week
would you provide those services to mr
depp
40 to 60 hours
and can you describe generally your
interactions with mr depp in the time
that you've worked for him
pleasant always upbeat
do you know the defendant in this case
amber heard
yes
when did you first meet miss hurd
after the filming of the rum diary
project
can you describe generally your
interactions with miss hurt
pleasant claw joe very respectful
and so in your time working with mr depp
did you uh ever observe mr depps and
miss herd's interactions with one
another
yes
and can you describe those interactions
generally please
very cordial very uh
aware that people are around them very
very friendly
did you ever see them argue
yes
can you describe what you observed about
those arguments
it would be initiated by her
she would try to engage with him he
would tell me to turn the music up
so um where did these arguments take
place
in the car
do you recall how many times you
witnessed them argue
twice
mr jenkins turning your attention to
april 21st 2016.
uh can you tell the jury what you recall
about that day
did you repeat the question sir sure so
turning your attention to april 21st
2016
can you tell the jury what you recall
about that day
it was the birthday party being held at
the penthouse
and when you say the penthouse what are
you referring to
it's the eastern columbia build
and what were you doing that evening
that evening i was assigned security on
the detail
were you inside the residence while the
birthday party was taking place
i was in the cp the command post that's
stationed on the same floor right
outside of the elevator
and did you interact with miss hurt at
all that evening
yes i did
congrats to getting her clients
keys
parking
making sure no one else was on the floor
that wasn't invited to the party
were there any issues at the birthday
party uh at the time
uh that you were present at the
penthouses
no issues except for the boss did not
show up
and do you recall what time you left
that day
11 15 pm that evening
and mr jenkins what happened the next
day april 22nd 2016.
i arrived early 10 45
i went upstairs to the penthouse i was
informed by amber that she got a fight
with johnny last night
she threw his personal property over the
balcony
into the streets ninth and broadway
and when you say personal property what
are you referring to
his phone wallet
credit cards passports everything that's
in his wallet
did uh miss hurt say anything else to
you about this uh altercation
nothing except she
they were fighting
so what what did you do after miss heard
informed you that she'd thrown mr depp's
personal property off the balcony
formulated a plan with norm from the
office to use the find my phone app
hit the streets and
try to get lucky
did you end up finding mr depp's phone
yes i did skid row
probably six miles from the house
and who had the who had the phone
a
homeless gentleman unhoused gentleman
i approached him about the phone he was
honest he returned it i gave him a
reward for it and what was the reward
420
chicken tacos chips apples fiji water
after finding mr depp's phone what did
you do
i returned to the penthouse showed the
phone to amber that i retrieved it i
left it in the sheet in the cp for the
evening security to return it to mr deb
so after figuring out uh things with the
phone what what happened next
what happened next is i walked amber to
the car we got everybody in the car
she's on her way to coachella i went
back to the penthouse to retrieve the
dogs and the luggage
were you also going to coachella with
miss heard
yes i was i was the transportation for
amber and her friends while she was at
coachella
so how did you get to coachella
enjoy the suv
provided by johnny
put the animals and all the luggage in
and headed out to the bin and the the
morning of april 22nd did you see uh any
injuries on misheard
no marks
no engines
um and so
driving out to coachella did anyone
drive with you
i was in the car alone except for the
end
and how did miss heard get to coachella
she drove her mustang
was anyone else in her car
she was with i believe her sister and
one other friend her assistant
and do you know how many days uh miss
heard and her friends were planning to
stay at coachella
so the following monday i believe it's
the 25th of april
we departed
and do you recall where miss heard was
staying at coachella
we're staying at the parker
boutique hotels there in palm springs
outside of coachella were you also
staying at the parker hotel
i also stayed there
and so did you attend coachella for work
or for pleasure
for work
and what was your job that weekend
provide security and transportation
animal care
amber's rolling assistant take care of
her whatever she needed while she was
there at the parker or didn't uh out
travel
do you recall what time approximately
you arrived at the parker hotel on april
22nd
around
5 30 maybe quarter to six
and and what did miss heard and her
friends do that evening april 22nd
that evening
we arrived
we were assigned the rooms we went with
the
[Music]
with the
staff of the parker hotel around to the
suites where we were staying they let us
in
we let all the luggage in
and we proceeded to
[Music]
plan for that evening to depart by 7
seven fifteen is to get to the festival
there
and and how did miss hurt and her
friends get from the hotel to the
festival that evening
i drove them directly to them
and did you have any discussions with
miss heard on the way to coachella that
evening
we had a conversation pertaining to the
surprise she left in the boss's bed
prior to leaving the apartment and when
you refer to the surprise in the boss's
bed what are you referring to
the defecation
and what did miss heard say about the
defecation in mr duff's bed
a horrible practical jerk gone wrong
mr jenkins what observations did you
make about miss heard at coachella in
april 2016
she had no worry she was there to whoop
it up it's her birthday she's with her
friends
and how often were you with her that
weekend
was with her every day she went to the
venue from the time that we interacted
with the wallet incident
the night before at the party all the
way until monday we returned
with the pets
and the luggage
and did you uh observe anything about
miss heard's health that weekend
she got sick
do you know what's sick at the venue
second night do you know what cosmis
herd to be sick
she was eating the magic mushrooms and
drinking red wine on an empty stomach
and uh how do you know that she drank
red wine and took magic
mushrooms i saw the room service and i
went to their room to collect them to
take them out that evening
excuse me is that something you
witnessed
i witnessed it
and what did you do uh in response to
miss heard being sick at coachella
i collected her
got her in the vehicle
she didn't want anybody else to know
that she was sick take her back to the
parker alone i took her to the 7-eleven
where i retrieved hydrating fluids advil
and
better have those got her back to the
parker got her into the suite and then
went back to pick up everyone else
and mr james when you said uh miss heard
got sick do you recall what her symptoms
were
yeah she was throwing up
mr jenkins did you see any injuries of
any kind i misheard april 22 2016.
no injuries i'll sustain you so yes
what about the rest of that weekend mr
jenkins any injuries that you saw
no injuries
um
have you ever witnessed any physical
abuse between mr depp and miss heard
no
thank you mr jenkins nothing further all
right cross examination
good afternoon mr jenkins
good afternoon
so just just to be clear on the
chronology
you met mr depp in 1993 is that right
correct and you've worked for him ever
since
often on yes okay and your your salary
is paid by mr depp correct
salary
no
you receive pay for the work that you do
for mr yes correct of course yes of
course and what mr depp's security is
your highest priority in your job
correct
yes you did you're loyal to mr yeah
and his family you're loyal to mr depp
right
yes
now i want to turn to the the
the night of april 21st 2016.
you just just to recap you said you were
working a security shift at amber's
birthday
at the eastern columbia building that
evening correct
correct and you said that your shift
ended around 11 15. correct
correct
and
you you said the boss still hadn't shown
up by the time that you left the eastern
columbia building right
correct
so you have no idea
where mr depp was or what he was doing
from 9 30 p.m that evening until
at least 11 15 when you left the eastern
columbia building right
no i do know what he was doing he was
attending to his mother
you weren't with him
i had information okay
all right
that's information that you
that you received but you you have no
personal knowledge of that
have no reasons i have no reason to
doubt it it came from sean okay
oh
oh okay so mr mr bet told you that
the boss is out there right mr bett told
you that he was tending to his mother
that night
he didn't say mother he said the boss
was out late i'm aware of what the
situation was the time frame
he's with his mother okay all right
interesting
okay um
and did you have any understanding that
he had a meeting with his new business
manager earlier that evening where he
was told that he was running out of
money and that his taxes hadn't been
paid in years did you have any
understanding of that objection for
anyone else objection foundation culture
speculation i'll sustain the objection
next question
and you didn't see mr depp that night
right
no i didn't know okay so you came back
the next morning to escort amber to
coachella
right yes and you say that amber told
you that she had thrown
mr depp's phone off the roof
correct and did you come to understand
that
mr depp had thrown her phone off the
roof that evening prior to when amber
threw mr depp's phone off the roof
she informed me of that
okay she informed you of that so when
you went outside
to look for
mr depp's phone you you weren't looking
for miss herd's phone were you
she had her phone she had her phone she
was trying to
re-download and back it up okay so she
you were only looking for mr depp's
phone when you went when you went
downstairs to this to the to uh to try
to you found it with a with an unhoused
person you said correct
correct okay and you did you did i hear
you right that you said it was six miles
away where you found the phone
correct
it actually wasn't six miles away it was
it was actually right below the building
the ecb building correct okay let's not
can you pull up um
does he have a way to see documents that
just just him your honor yes
um could you please pull up uh
the witness statement mr jenkins mr
jenkins do you do you remember giving
testimony on mr depp's behalf in the uk
trial yes i did
and
um you gave you gave a witness statement
first in in writing correct do you
remember that
yes and then you were examined by the
attorneys in the trial correct
correct okay
can you see on your screen the statement
uh that's
do you see a witness statement
yes i see it it says witness statement
of starling jenkins right
and this is the statement that you
wrote and signed as part of the uh the
uk trial on behalf of mr depp correct
correct okay
if you can scroll please to page three
of the document
and
mr jenkins i'm going to read you
what you wrote in paragraph 13
okay
and
we can go from there
on paragraph 13 you wrote
in your witness statement in the uk
trial
the find my iphone application indicated
that johnny's phone was somewhere on the
streets below the balcony of the
residence
did i read that right
if that's what it says that's what it
says i'm telling you the phone was in
skid row okay so the gentleman that
found it i have the location where the
phone was found isn't skid row just a
few blocks away from the eastern
columbia building
no it's uh it's on sixth and
main i guess depending on what area you
are okay so so one of these two sworn
statements either what you just said in
court just now that it was found six
miles away or this one of these is false
correct
uh
it's
just inadequate as far as the location
the location is not below
the
penthouse it's not on broadway it's
found on broadway by the unhoused man
and then he lives off of skid row okay
now let's move on to coachella please
you
you were with uh amber and her friends
that weekend at coachella um and you
testified a little bit about what you
saw
is it fair to say that amber and her
friends were having a good time that
weekend
yes
and there were thousands of other people
at that music festival too correct
correct okay to your to
were you aware that amber's sister
whitney was
pregnant and sober that weekend
wasn't my information was my knowledge
were you aware that amber's sister
whitney threw up in a parking lot that
weekend
no okay to your knowledge and
understanding mr jenkins um there's
nothing wrong with wanting to spend time
with your friends at a music festival
after being abused by your husband right
what abuse
that's not an abnormal thing to want to
be around your friends correct
she was partying up with her friends
she's partying it up and you said you
didn't hear anything about she didn't
say anything to you about domestic
violence having taken place correct
nothing in the car pertaining to that
would it surprise you that she might not
want to talk to someone who had worked
for her husband for around 23 years at
that point about domestic violence would
that surprise you
objection speculation your honor sustain
the objection next question
mr texted you on may 12
2016 asking you to call her correct
correct
and you did not bother to respond to
that text correct
correct
and that was the last communication that
you had with her
correct correct
now you weren't um just to be clear you
weren't at amber's house on orange
avenue in march 2013 when johnny was
there correct
i might have driven him to the location
i'm familiar with the address but you
didn't enter the house at any point in
march 2013 correct
depending on if you had luggage or just
going upstairs i might have but you
didn't hang out with them inside the
house
right
hurry up and wait in the car sir
and you weren't at the hicksville
trailer palace in late may or early june
2013 right
no
you weren't on a plane flight from
boston to los angeles in may 2014
correct with with johnny and amber
you weren't in the you weren't with mr
depp and amber in the bahamas in august
2014 correct
correct
you weren't with mr depp and amber in
tokyo in january 2015 correct
uh no i was not there correct you
weren't with mr depp and amber in
australia in march 2015 correct
correct
you weren't at thanksgiving with them in
penthouse five of the eastern columbia
building in november 2015 correct
uh
i believe i was there you didn't work in
the detail i don't have the schedule but
i might have been assigned to detail
that day you wanted to holiday sure you
don't have any specific recollection of
that one way or the other though correct
i would probably say i was on duty that
day okay it's the holiday okay um you
weren't celebrating thanksgiving in
penthouse five with them that evening
correct
i was in the cp okay and that's that's a
separate room correct
separate room on the same level correct
and you weren't in the bahamas in late
december 2015 correct
with them correct
you weren't in the ecb with just the two
of them the night of december 15 2015
correct
that is uh
right before the christmas party i
believe
correct
and finally you weren't in the penthouse
of the eastern columbia building on the
night of may 21st 2016 with mr depp and
miss heard correct
correct
and and and you'd agree that you have no
personal knowledge of what went on
between mr depp and miss heard behind
closed doors correct
correct
nothing further thank you all right
redirect
just very quick on your honor do we have
um
mr jenkins witness statement
or perhaps
and if we could go to the third page
please
mr jenkins directing your attention to
paragraph 13 which mr rottenborn had you
look at just a second ago
yes
he read the first sentence of that
uh witness statement
um
find my phone find my iphone application
indicating that giant's phone was
somewhere on the streets below the
balcony residence walked out could you
could you please read for the jury the
the second part of the
that paragraph
i walked out onto the street did not see
the phone i then
asked several homeless people if they
had the phone one homeless man admitted
to me that he had the phone returned the
phone to me in exchange for the
following
425 in cash three chicken tacos two bags
of chips four apples two apples four
bottles of water
and so do you do you recall where you
found the iphone that day
yes i do objection asked and answered
all right i'll sustain the objection
next question
mr jenkins moving to uh coachella
mr rottenborn asked you about
whitney heard do you know who that is
yes i do do you know the difference
between whitney heard and amber heard
yes i do and who was sick that is the
boss why
one is the boss's sister-in-law who was
sick that day at coachella
amber was sick
thank you nothing further all right is
this witness subject to recall
no your honor all right mr jenkins
you're
you're free from testimony and therefore
you're free to to do whatever you need
to do or you can watch the proceedings
it's up to you but uh you're you're done
for today though thank you sir
thank you ronnie thank you for the court
all right have a good day
you're awesome all right let's
all right i think it's close enough to 5
30 that i think we've had enough
of a week ladies and gentlemen at this
time we're going to go ahead and
be done with the testimony for this week
although since i won't see until monday
i want to give you
the long jury instruction that i give
you every every thursday evening just so
we all remember our responsibilities
okay
so at this time remember that you are
not to read anything about this case you
are not to watch anything about this
case you are not to listen to anything
about this case this applies to
television newspapers magazines the
internet and any online sites
further you are not to read watch or
listen to anything about this case on
any social networking sites such as
twitter facebook instagram snapchat
blogs or similar sites in addition you
must not communicate with anyone about
the case whether in person over the
phone by email text or instant messaging
or by any other electronic or
non-electronic means this includes your
friends family co-workers acquaintances
and strangers i also instruct you that
you cannot do any research or make
inquiries about this case whether online
or by any other means for example you
cannot look uh look information up on
the internet that is related to this
case or related to the persons involved
in this case normally you consult
dictionaries or other reference
materials what you learn about this case
is limited to what you learn in the four
walls of this courtroom when proceedings
are underway you also may not
communicate about this case or the
person's involved in this case with your
fellow jurors okay hope you have a good
weekend it's supposed to be great
weather on saturday go outside get some
fresh air okay and just enjoy your
weekend and we'll see you back monday at
10 okay thank you so much
all right
and as always mr mr depp and miss heard
please do not do any posting on social
media and do not talk to the press i
appreciate it and have a good weekend uh
for the attorneys tomorrow um what time
how many did we do our homework this
week yes
we did
work in progress okay so are we still
doing
19 tomorrow
twenties you added one for me that's
lovely
okay great so we'll do 20 tomorrow so i
would suggest eight o'clock can
everybody be here at eight
sound good
okay we'll be here at 8am and we'll just
do them until we're done so bring a lot
of meals okay
all right we'll see you tomorrow then
thank you have a good evening
you